bonjour à toutes et à tous
mes chers collègues nous accueillons
aujourd'hui madame Sarah el haïri
secrétaire d'État chargée de la jeunesse
et du service national universel pour
une audition consacrée au service
national universel et c'est nu donc
Madame la Ministre cette audition prévue
de longue date prend évidemment une
coloration particulière à la lumière des
événements violents car récemment connu
notre pays et auquel ont notamment pris
part un certain nombre d'adolescents un
tel constat nous amène naturellement en
tant que responsable politique à nous
interroger sont sans complaisance mais
avec lucidité sur les raisons multiples
et complexes qui ont pu mener une partie
de la jeunesse de notre pays a participé
à de tels actes il nous invite également
à rechercher les voix et moyen
pertinents afin de reconstruire du
commun au sein de notre société les
mesures que nous devons mettre en oeuvre
pour prévenir relève de l'ensemble des
champs de l'action publique et de
l'ensemble des acteurs publics comme
privés nationaux comme locaux
ce n'est pas le seul mais le s&u compte
tenu de sa vocation apparaît comme un
levier spécifique essentiel pour
favoriser la cohésion et l'engagement au
service de l'intérêt général madame la
ministre les questions que je souhaite
vous poser vont au delà des événements
de l'actualité récente auquel je faisais
référence mais elles y font toutefois
écho le SMU a vocation a renforcé la
cohésion nationale favoriser la mixité
sociale et territoriale inciter les
jeunes à s'engager et contribuer à leur
orientation basée sur le volontariat il
a d'abord fait l'objet d'une première
expérience dans 13 départements et à
concerner
1941 jeunes en 2019 vous confirmez les
chiffres oui lors des débats budgétaires
sur le web des finances pour 2023 le
gouvernement avait indiqué que le
dispositif avait vocation à accueillir
64000 volontaires au sein des séjours de
cohésion en 2023 cet objectif a-t-il été
atteint et par ailleurs disposez-vous
d'éléments statistiques sur la
représentativité sociale et territoriale
des jeunes participant au séjour de
cohésion qui correspond à la phase une
des dispositifs qu'en est-il des phases
2 la participation à des missions
d'intérêt général et 3 l'engagement
volontaire et sur ces questions je vous
laisse la parole madame la ministre
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés je suis
particulièrement heureuse de pouvoir
avoir ce temps particulièrement précieux
et important pour rentrer dans un retour
mais explicite transparent évidemment
sur le service national universel
d'autant plus que nous venons de
d'accueillir et de raccompagner
l'ensemble des jeunes qui ont fait les
séjours de juin et de juillet madame la
Présidente les séjours de juillet comme
je vous disais se termine mais plus
particulièrement c'est vrai que les
dernières actualités ont mis en lumière
un besoin certain d'engagement de
citoyenneté de civisme de cohésion
surtout également parce que ça a été
rappelé d'ailleurs dans une audition 10
heures le par le ministre de l'Intérieur
la grande jeunesse en réalité des jeunes
questionnés énormément moyen d'âge étant
autour de 17 ans cependant les plus
jeunes avaient je crois entre 9 et 11
ans ce qui dit quelque chose de très
particulier le FC nu mais vous l'avez
rappelé madame la Présidente c'est
d'avoir un parcours et je crois que
c'est important de revenir
il a été longtemps parfois
malheureusement caricaturé ou simplement
réduit à la phase une qui est le séjour
de cohésion mais c'est plus que ça en
fait le signe et c'est ça qui est
important de rappeler le SMS c'est
d'abord oui un séjour de cohésion entre
15 et 17 ans ou on assume un
enseignement des engagement du
patriotisme de la citoyenneté du civisme
des apprentissages comme les gestes qui
sauvent qui ont d'ailleurs permis hier
en particulier je suis pas je suis assez
touché parce que c'est sur mon
territoire mais en Loire-Atlantique à
trois jeunes Étienne Quentin et Paul de
sauver une jeune femme de la noyade
parce que en fait il maîtrisait donc là
la question la question c'est comment on
fait que pour que nos jeunes et les
moyens et bien d'être utile d'être utile
aux plus âgé à leurs voisins à leur
famille et de finalement pouvoir prendre
leur place c'est bien ces apprentissages
là qui sont au cœur de la phase une donc
du séjour de cohésion mais le sneu c'est
également un idéal un idéal de de
finalement de fibres citoyennes et de
responsabilité que nous avons dans notre
commun territorial ou plutôt nation et
là c'est quelle forme d'engagement je
peux amener quelle forme quelle plage je
prends dans la société et c'est
exactement l'esprit de la mission
d'intérêt général 82 heures ou en
réalité deux semaines qui permet à des
jeunes de toutes de tout milieu social
de tout territoire et bien finalement de
prendre pleinement leur place dans un
EHPAD dans chez jeunes sapeurs-pompiers
ou encore plus largement au sein en
réalité d'associations caritative je
pense au resto du coeur à la protection
civile en particulier en pensant
évidemment au risque climatiques que
nous connaissons l'été
ces temps ils sont ils ne sont pas
opposés avec la phase 3 en réalité
puisque c'est une sorte de goût de
découverte d'apprentissage ils répondent
aussi aux besoins essentiels que nous
rappelle les structures associatives de
comment on crée une fibre citoyenne
bénévole comme on accompagne la future
génération de bénévoles dans nos
associations et qui permet finalement
sur cette phase 3 qui est un peu plus
longue et bien aux jeunes de choisir un
engagement soit sous les drapeaux donc
sous la forme de réserve réserve
militaire gendarmerie armée ou encore
rejoindre les réserves civiles de nos
armées sous un statut civil et je pense
évidemment au service civique qui
accueillent une grande partie de des
jeunes qui font le choix d'un engagement
de plus de six mois donc c'est entre 6
mois et un an entre leur fin de séjour
donc 16 ans et leur 25 ans ou encore la
coopération à l'international dans des
structures ONG ou organisation pour le
coup je pense à nos instituts français
parce que le rayonnement Le rayonnement
de la France il est évidemment sur notre
territoire dans les solidarités
quotidiennes et de proximité mais il est
aussi en dehors de nos frontières et je
pense que donner les moyens à notre
jeunesse de prendre pleinement sa part
dans notre projet de société c'est leur
faire d'abord confiance bien sûr je
crois que c'est un acte de confiance
mais c'est aussi créer des repères
communs et comment faire pour qu'une
génération soit unie si elle n'a pas de
comment si elle n'a pas un moment vécu
quelque chose qu'il a lié qui lui
donnait fondamentalement ce goût de nous
sommes oui nous sommes le peuple d'un
grand pays en réalité malgré les
réalités sociales différentes
territoriales différentes nous avons
quelque chose qui nous dépasse et se
dépassement c'est le goût de
l'engagement pas entre autres et à quel
moment au-delà des projets bien sûr qui
sont portés par le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale et ministre de
l'éducation nationale sur la question de
la mixité de la carte scolaire
évidemment des moyens supplémentaires
pour les territoires que dans le plus
besoin à quel moment un jeune rural
partage 15 jours de sa vie avec un jeune
urbain à quel moment un jeune des
quartiers nord de Marseille se rend
compte que la réalité de la vie en
Creuse ou chez moi dans ma terre de
naissance dans Loir-et-Cher ont du
commun comment c'est les difficultés
parfois de mobilité le choix de la des
offres de formation à quel moment un
jeune d'un établissement que je ne
souhaitons pas opposer de
l'établissement privé d'un établissement
public se rendre compte qu'en réalité
ils ont bien plus en commun que ce que
ils pouvaient parfois
fantasmer ou caricaturé
par là et ben ces engagements là ce
temps qui est particulier permet ça
puisque il n'y a pas de coupe fil comme
à Disney qui permettrait finalement à
certains d'avoir un traitement premium
au VIP il n'y a pas de différence entre
des jeunes qui seraient de classe
favorisées aux classes plus défavorisées
ou plus difficile on ne demande pas aux
jeunes s'ils viennent d'établissement
professionnel ou au contraire
d'établissements généraux d'excellence
non on leur demande simplement de venir
de s'engager se mobiliser et en réalité
d'être à la hauteur de de finalement ce
qui va les attendre un ensemble de
droits acquis avec une devoir de
d'engagement derrière un accompagnement
qui est fait en particulier par trois
types de de personnalité forte d'abord
des hommes et des femmes qui viennent de
l'éducation nationale des CPE des
infirmières des infirmières scolaires
des enseignants des proviseurs qui
viennent volontairement depuis le début
du SMU c'est 15000 hommes et femmes qui
ont fait le choix de porter cet uniforme
Bordeaux pour accompagner cette jeunesse
c'est des hommes et des femmes qui en
plus de leur travail puisque c'est
aujourd'hui des contrats qui sont des
contrats ponctuels font le choix de
faire grandir le goût oui de
l'engagement de la nation et de la
République dans le cœur de cette
jeunesse on lui donnant des opportunités
c'est plus de 127 structures centre
d'accueil dans notre territoire en
grande majorité des centres d'accueil
plutôt communaux ou de l'éducation
populaire c'est des conventions qui sont
menées avec des grandes structures
d'éducation populaire je pense
évidemment à la Ligue de l'enseignement
aux Francas mea aller où Lagrange à
l'UCPA UFC c'est les grandes structures
qui en réalité encadre pour un tiers les
jeunes parce qu'ils sont formés ce sont
des animateurs des éducateurs c'est une
dans le cadre du projet pédagogique
c'est complémentaire et enfin évidemment
c'est jamais des femmes qui viennent des
corps en uniformes et qui ont servi sur
nos drapeaux qui sont dans un statut
civil quand ils encadrent nos jeunes
mais ce sont des hommes et des femmes
qui ont le goût aussi en réalité d'une
autre forme d'engagement gendarmes
pompiers
ancien policier ou ancien ou ancien
militaire ou des réservistes qui
irriguent en réalité nos territoires
mesdames Messieurs le service national
universel c'est d'abord 57% de filles
oui il y a plus de filles que de jeunes
garçons je j'y vois un goût de
l'engagement certain mais c'est
également
5,7% de jeunes qui viennent des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville 2,7%
de jeunes en situation de handicap parce
que oui le SNU est un projet qui est
inclusif profondément d'abord
des jeunes qui étaient principalement
avec des handicaps qui le déclaraient et
ensuite cette année on a fait le choix
d'aller un peu plus loin avec un centre
qui a été expérimental à Garches où il y
avait des jeunes avec des handicaps un
peu plus lourds en tout cas qui
nécessitaient des parce que le lieu le
permettait et c'est parce que ce projet
ne doit permettre ne doit ne doit être
interdit à personne parce que c'est ça
le rêve français c'est si tu veux si tu
as envie alors il y aura des hommes et
des femmes pour t'accompagner pour te
permettre de vivre ça jamais le coup
financier ne sera un frein jamais la
situation personnelle ou sociale ne sera
en fin et au-delà de ça le projet est
très clair je sais que ça progression
prend du temps mais je répondrai à vos
questions madame la Présidente plus de
2000 jeunes 13 départements en 2019 en
réalité 2020 seule la Nouvelle-Calédonie
était à l'époque
préservée de la covid et ont pu vivre
des séjours en 2021 15000 15000 jeunes
qui ont fait des séjours de cohésion
22000 jeunes en 2022 2023 n'étant pas
encore terminé mais nous sommes d'ores
et déjà pour apporter d'un certain
nombre de chiffres madame la Présidente
à plus de 40 000 jeunes qui ont déjà
effectué le séjour de de cohésion et qui
s'engage sur les missions qui suivent
d'intérêt général mais surtout il y a au
plus haut nous étions sur une liste de
plus de 10000 jeunes qui souhaitaient
bénéficier en train de participer à ce
projet et donc comme l'année n'est pas
terminée je projette en tout cas
l'accompagnement de cette liste
complémentaire pour les prochains défis
du SMU c'est évidemment pour moi
d'accompagner en réalité l'arrivée du
service national universel sur le temps
scolaire pour ceux qui le souhaitent
puisque nous avons proposé aux
enseignants et au chef d'établissement
établissements publics et privés de
permettre à des classes d'être des
classes engagées donc là c'est engager
c'est quoi c'est un enseignant qui est
volontaire qui décide que la citoyenneté
l'engagement et le civisme est une
priorité pour sa classe qui construit un
projet pédagogique avec évidemment les
moyens qui vont avec puisqu'il y a une
dotation qui est prévue avec des sorties
scolaires des témoignages la découverte
de structures associatives sur son
propre territoire et qui permettra à un
moment donné et bien de partir sur un
séjour de cohésion avec l'ensemble de sa
classe en ayant la possibilité
évidemment de d'approfondir
quatre thèmes que nous avons choisi en
tout cas comme prioritaire c'est-à-dire
la mémoire la question évidemment
environnementale mais il y a également
la question du sport et les JO parce
qu'on sait à quel point le sport
également est émancipation et permet de
transmettre des valeurs absolument
essentielles et enfin l'aide aux
populations et face et ce en réalité
comment réagir face aux catastrophes
naturelles puisque nous avons vécu l'été
dernier de grands incendies des crues
70% de notre territoire et à risque de
cru mais il y a des canicules alors
comment faire si nos jeunes le
souhaitent comment ils participent à la
solidarité la plus proche et la plus
locale en tout cas ils pourront faire ce
choix là si le souhaitent des
incitations bien sûr puisque le projet
il est il est reconnu pour ses
compétences transversales développées
donc pédagogiquement parlant je parle
c'est un moment qui est important parce
qu'il vient compléter l'engagement
volontaire personnel les jeunes
continueront à être volontaires si l'on
souhaite pendant le temps des vacances
mais j'espère qu'un maximum
d'établissements en tout cas ceux qui
pensent que
ce sont des valeurs essentielles à
partager pourront évidemment postuler
jusqu'à la fin octobre de mémoire pour
des séjours qui commenceraient dès le
mois de mars c'est un projet
particulièrement dynamique qui a besoin
de vous mesdames messieurs les députés
parce que à chaque fois que vous visitez
un centre à chaque fois que vous prenez
du temps pour échanger avec ces jeunes
et bien c'est un petit bout de France un
petit bout de République qu'il voit
c'est une écharpe c'est un message de
confiance mais aussi du coup un devoir
de responsabilité parce que quand on
s'intéresse à eux quand les accompagne
et bien dans le fond il compte les
repères c'est aussi fait pour donner un
cap et je crois que vous y participez
très grandement à chaque fois que vous
prenez du temps pour témoigner de votre
mandat bien sûr mais au-delà de votre
mandat de votre engagement mesdames
messieurs les députés je j'apporterai
évidemment un ensemble de réponses très
spécifiques mais un point qui me tenait
particulièrement à coeur pendant ces
séjours les jeunes les plus fragiles
parlent
témoignent ont un accompagnement au delà
je pense de l'accompagnement évidemment
du bilan de santé comme on a connu à
d'autres époques des jeunes filles qui
plus en majorité qui qui voit la parole
se libérer parce qu'on a des temps
évidemment de formation sur des
essentiels je pense évidemment aux
questions de harcèlement de
cyber-harcèlement de violence sexuelles
et sexistes également et je crois que le
renforcement de notre cohésion passe
également par le renforcement de l'accès
aux droits et cet engagement là et bien
il est tenu pendant le service à son
anniversaire voilà madame la présidente
des propos liminaires assez courts pour
tenir le timing qui est souhaité
merci Madame la Ministre des propos
courts mais dansent et donc nous allons
avoir maintenant les orateurs de groupe
et nous allons commencer par le groupe
Renaissance avec Fabienne Colboc merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
vous l'avez dit en 2019 le SMU a été
déployé pour les jeunes âgés de 15 à 17
ans le SNU se déroule en plusieurs
phases stage de cohésion mission
d'intérêt général et un engagement
citoyen au-delà de trois mois cette
phase assez propre objectif et permet
aux jeunes de développer des compétences
telles que le travail d'équipe le sens
des responsabilités et la solidarité les
perspectives au cercles par le SNU sont
nombreuses ce dispositif permet d'abord
aux jeunes de découvrir de nouveaux
horizons de développer leur esprit
critique mais aussi de favoriser leur
insertion professionnelle en offrant aux
jeunes des formations et des stages en
lien avec leurs projets d'avenir il
permet de redonner un cap et du sens à
l'avenir de la jeunesse cependant le s&u
rencontre certains défis certains jeunes
peuvent ne pas être motivés par ce
programme et le considérer comme une
contrainte afin de susciter engagement
des jeunes vous avez notamment annoncé
le lancement du dispositif classe engagé
permettant aux jeunes de réaliser le
stage de cohésion sur des périodes
scolaires par ailleurs la mixité sociale
au sein des groupes peut être difficile
à atteindre malgré ses défis le SNU a
connu des avancées significatives depuis
sa mise en place de plus en plus de
jeunes y participent chaque année ce qui
témoigne de l'intérêt croissant pour ce
programme se sont prêts comme vous
l'avez dit 50000 jeunes qui ont déjà
participé au SNU depuis sa création les
retours des jeunes qui ont participé au
s&u sont globalement positifs il
souligne l'importance de cette
expérience dans leur développement
personnel leur ouverture d'esprit et
leur engagement citoyen j'ai pu le
vérifier auprès du Centre SNU de mon
département d'Indre-et-Loire où j'ai le
plaisir à chaque fois de rencontrer ces
jeunes engagés madame la ministre
pourriez-vous nous donner les
perspectives d'évolution que vous
envisagez pour le SMU en plus du
dispositif classe engagé comment
favoriser l'engagement des jeunes venant
de tout nos territoires qui sont en
quête de sens parfois au-delà même du
SNU qui n'est pas obligatoire je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée pour le
rassemblement national Caroline
Parmentier merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je voudrais très concrètement attirer
votre attention sur les difficultés
rencontrer cette année par une jeune
candidate pour intégrer le SNU je tiens
tout d'abord à préciser qu'il s'agit
d'un projet intéressant mais de plus en
plus fragilisé par son côté gadget
présidentiel et par le fait qu'il ne
touche qu'une toute petite partie de la
population qu'il devrait concerner et
qu'il a raté son objectif de m'exciter
social premier point il n'y a pas assez
de place l'une de mes proches est
inscrite au SMU en février dernier elle
a été placée sur liste d'attentes
combien de temps à l'avance faut-il
s'inscrire pour espérer avoir une place
le 5 juillet dernier au soir elle a reçu
un message lui disant qu'elle pouvait
rejoindre son centre de SNU avant 22h30
le soir même dernier délai puisqu'il y
avait eu semble-t-il des désistements de
dernière seconde mais elle n'avait plus
la possibilité matérielle de le faire
d'où déception et frustration j'imagine
que de nombreux jeunes étaient dans son
cas
rappelons que les saignes avaient été
présentés en 2018 par Emmanuel Macron
comme la grande réforme de société du
quinquennat et qu'aujourd'hui 5 ans
après donc même ceux qui souhaitent le
rejoindre et qui ont la volonté de
l'intégrer ne le peuvent toujours pas le
terme de volontariat en l'occurrence
n'est pas juste compte tenu de cette
difficulté comment justifier vous la
rupture d'égalité que crée le bonus
accordée sur parcoursup entre les
adolescents ayant participé au s&u et
ceux qui n'ont pas pu y participer
malgré leur volonté comment
prévoyez-vous d'améliorer le dispositif
et où en est-on de votre proposition de
l'intégrer dans le parcours scolaire sur
la base du volontariat comment assurer
la logistique nécessaire à l'accueil de
800 000 jeunes les structures adaptées
et le nombre d'encadrant nécessaire je
vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour elle et
fille et au Walter merci madame la
présidente madame la secrétaire d'État
lorsque Jacques Chirac annonce le 28 mai
1996 la fin du service militaire
obligatoire c'est un soulagement pour
nombre de jeunes hommes certains s'y
retrouver tout à fait mais pour les
autres les alternatives n'étaient pas
accessibles à tous et ressembler parfois
à une punition l'objection de conscience
entraînant par exemple le doublement du
temps nécessaire pour remplir ses
obligations nationales et nombreux sont
ceux qui mirent en péril leur santé
voire plus pour y échapper nombreux sont
ceux pour qui les souvenirs de cette
année sous les drapeaux ne sont pas de
bons souvenirs cependant nous étions
quelques-uns à penser que l'erreur du
président Chirac était de ne pas le
remplacer par un service national où
l'option militaire ne serait justement
qu'une option et où chaque jeune adulte
pourrait choisir sa manière de s'engager
au service de l'intérêt général une
façon essentielle de donner à chacun à
chacune un sentiment d'utilité et
d'appartenance à la communauté nationale
et voilà que sur une lubie du président
Macron le SNU viendrait combler cette
lacune mais voilà le SNU a tout faux
premier aberration il s'adresse aux
jeunes de 15 à 17 ans il ne s'agit donc
pas de l'engagement de jeunes majeurs au
service de la nation mais bien d'un
stage de citoyenneté inapte destiné à
redresser voire adresser des adolescents
considérés à priori comme mal élevé
deuxième aberration il adopte une forme
édulcorée du service militaire réduisant
les valeurs de la République au port de
l'uniforme et au lever des couleurs
troisième aberration de recul en recul
vous chargez finalement l'éducation
nationale de rattraper le coup en
espérant trouver assez d'enseignants de
seconde volontaire pour priver leurs
élèves de deux semaines de cours et en y
ajoutant une indigne carotte promettre
aux élèves qui supplieront des points
supplémentaires sur parcoursup
que de contorsion pour imposer contre
toute logique cette mauvaise idée je
vous en conjure madame la secrétaire
d'État renoncer au SNU utiliser les
crédits à louer pour soutenir notre
école publique qui en a bien besoin ou
pour relancer les colonies de vacances
écoutez nos propositions pour un
véritable service citoyen réservé aux
jeunes adultes et laissez l'éducation
des adolescents aux professionnels merci
merci monsieur le député
je rappelle quand même que c'est sur la
base du volontariat donc les jeunes mal
élevés je sais pas voilà pour les
républicains Isabelle Périgot
ah non non je sais pas systématiquement
non monsieur judo lève le doigt parce
que il en est aussi régulièrement
l'objet donc
à Mes Jeux
rassurez-vous c'est généralisé à tous
les oui je
suis d'abord c'est la je vous remercie
mesdames et messieurs députés qui
effectivement rappelle que c'est le rôle
de la présidente et je rappellerai aussi
que même vis-à-vis de mon groupe je l'ai
déjà fait à plusieurs reprises donc il
n'y a vraiment aucune
exclusion de ma part dans les remarques
que je peux faire c'est tous les groupes
sont concernés et c'est en fonction de
la façon dont les choses se passent pour
maintenir effectivement la sérénité dans
nos débats donc j'en étais au
républicains et à Isabelle Périgot
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le groupe les républicains est
évidemment très sensible au sujet qui
touche la Jeunesse et à la transmission
des valeurs de citoyenneté et de
cohésion sociale portée par le service
national universel les récentes
évènements montrent la nécessité
d'apprendre à notre jeunesse à faire
nations et de remobiliser autour de nos
valeurs communes ce service national
universel pourrait être l'un des moteurs
effectivement dans ma circonscription en
Seine-et-Marne l'internat d'excellence
de Sourdun est un des lieux qui a
accueilli cet été deux séjours du s&u je
me suis donc fait un devoir d'y assister
aux cérémonies de clôture de ces séjours
afin d'aller à la rencontre vous disiez
tout à l'heure de ces jeunes Français
qui ont souvent pour la plupart
de façon bénévole soif d'engagement à
l'origine le service national universel
a été créé je le disais pour favoriser
le sentiment d'unité nationale autour
des valeurs de citoyenneté d'engagement
de cohésion sociale mais permettez-moi
alors on a ministre de m'étonner de deux
choses tout d'abord lors de ces clôtures
de séjour j'ai quand même pu constater
qu'une certaine idéologie
transparaissait dans les restitutions ou
différentes présentations que pouvait
être faites par les ateliers auxquels
ils participaient tout au long du séjour
de ces jeunes engagés la question qui en
découle naturellement est donc simple
comment contrôler vous l'action des
encadrants et des intervenants lors de
ces séjours et ensuite en discutant avec
ces jeunes j'ai pu constater également
que de nombreux étaient ceux qui
venaient
de même milieu social souvent plutôt
issus de la ruralité alors que
l'objectif de ce SMU vous le disiez tout
à l'heure c'était une phase favoriser le
sentiment d'unité nationale et du rural
et de l'urbain alors que comptez-vous
faire madame la ministre pour favoriser
une meilleure mixité sociale auprès des
différentes promotions du SNU je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée pour les
démocrates Laurent Crozier
merci madame la présidente madame la
secrétaire d'État les valeurs de la
République jouent le rôle de ciment dans
l'unité de la nation elles sont ce qui
permet de faire cohésion ce qui unit les
Français cet amour de la France cet
amour de la République nous devons les
transmettre c'est une des missions qui
vous a été confiée par le biais du
service national universel le SNU est
bien plus qu'un projet c'est une
ambition celle de permettre à des jeunes
de régions différentes de milieux
sociaux différents de partager une
période de leur vie de s'émerveiller
ensemble de la richesse de notre
histoire de la grandeur de notre culture
et de notre patrimoine
quelle belle ambition que de vouloir
faire vivre intensément le lien entre
les jeunes et la République que de
vouloir développer la culture de
l'engagement du devoir et de la
solidarité à en croire le retour des
jeunes
le pari semblerait réussi ils disent
sortir grandir avec une vision élargie
du monde et une plus grande sensibilité
aux valeurs de solidarité un Besançon
dans ma circonscription j'ai vu des
jeunes fières de chanter ensemble
l'hymne national j'ai vu des jeunes
versés une larme à la fin de leur séjour
je rêve de les voir défiler le 14
juillet au comté aux côtés de nos
sapeurs-pompiers nous avons tellement
besoin de ces liens de cohésion
d'engagement et d'amitié dans cette
société très individualiste où la
caricature l'opposition systématique
l'invective sont tellement plus faciles
que la modération l'apaisement ou le
dépassement n'est ce pas cher collègue
et les filles
je conclurai madame la secrétaire d'État
en citant comme vous Léon Gauthier
dernier héros français du débarquement
Normandie qui nous a dernièrement
quittés il expliquait inlassablement que
s'il s'était engagé c'était parce qu'on
lui avait appris à aimer la France
madame la secrétaire d'État pensez-vous
que la généralisation du SMU puisse être
l'une des clés
merci monsieur le député pour les
socialistes apparentés fatihacy
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
c'est bon pour le micro normalement
maintenant donc je vous remercie madame
la présidente madame la ministre depuis
le début de mon mandat j'ai eu à de
nombreuses reprises pu vous faire part
de mon opposition ferme à la
généralisation du SNU au gré de vos
déclarations vous n'avez aucune
mensualité malheureusement mes doutes
sur celui-ci et il y a quelques semaines
par exemple après un énième changement
de cap nous apprenions que le SNU
empietterait désormais sur le temps
scolaire des lycéens et ce en total
déconnexion avec les programmes
scolaires de seconde puisqu'il n'y a eu
aucune modification du moins de ce que
je peux constater ou intégration de
l'usmu au Bulletin officiel dans ce sens
mais questionnements sont nombreux mais
je souhaite m'attarder aujourd'hui sur
la question de la sécurité qui entoure
l'organisation des séjours de cohésion
mais doute à cet égards ont été
renforcés lors de ma visite sur le
terrain dans un centre SNU que j'ai
effectué la semaine dernière dans mon
département de la Seine-Saint-Denis
ainsi j'ai pu y constater le profil très
très disparate des encadrants qui
derrière une terminologie non sans
rappeler l'armée tuteur de mes données
cadre de compagnie etc cash en fait de
très jeunes encadrants souvent sans BAFA
ni expérience précédente dans
l'animation
amené encadrer un public à peine plus
âgé que
l'absence de formation harmonisée de
profil type d'encadrants et de garantie
quand alors capacité à encadrer un
public mineur pose un véritable problème
de sécurité
en l'absence de standardisation minimale
du profil de ces encadrants nous courons
le risque de pratiques très aléatoire
d'un centrale autre et même parfois
dangereuse alors que nous parlons ici
d'enfants de 15 à 17 ans
lors de ma visite on m'a même confié
l'existence de certaines dérives liées à
certains profils d'encadrant comment
comptez-vous donc agir pour enfin
garantir la sécurité des mineurs
participant à ces séjours de cohésion et
comptez-vous enfin encadrer la formation
et le profil de ces encadrants madame la
ministre pouvez-vous laisser on ne peut
pas laisser au bon vouloir des
encadrants ou au hasard décider les
conditions de sécurité dans lesquelles
se déroule le SMU merci madame la
députée pour des écologistes
jean-claudeau
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre au lieu de commencer par vous
poser une question je vais y répondre
sans tarder même si vous aurez
évidemment tout loisir de revenir sur
nos divergences l'engagement est-il
unique la réponse à cette question est
bien évidemment non pourtant le
contraire est en filigrane derrière le
SNU l'uniforme l'uniformisation d'une
classe d'âge en uniforme moi qui est
passé un an sous les drapeaux je ne vois
toujours pas l'intérêt d'un service
réduit à une portion aussi congrue
derrière l'expression classe engagée on
insinue que seuls les élèves qui auront
fait le SNU seront engagés du moins
cocheront les cases de votre vision de
la société alors que les engagements de
nos jeunes sont divers il faut les
reconnaître ainsi dans la vie familiale
scolaire associatif militante ou
citoyenne pour une cause ou dans leur
commune vous disiez sur Télématin plus
de jeunes le feront mieux le pays se
portera madame la ministre je ne peux
souscrire à vos propos ce serait si
facile et c'est si réducteur élargissez
votre propos sans promouvoir l'ombre
également la pensée unique notre pays
ira mieux en offrant la jeunesse le
choix la confiance surtout la confiance
parfois quand les jeunes s'engagent pour
le climat et leur avenir on les qualifie
des côtes terroristes il y aurait donc
les bons et les mauvais engagements je
voudrais savoir si les budgets
supplémentaires attribués au SMU comme
les 1000 euros par classe engagées ou
les rémunérations des encadrants
encadrantes par le pacte se feront au
détriment d'autres missions de
l'éducation nationale ou du soutien la
vie associative et à l'éducation
populaire vous allez me répondre sur ce
point mais quoi qu'il en soit le prix à
payer me semble exorbitant pour un
objectif aléatoire ou illusoire 12 jours
pour la cohésion et la mixité 12 jours
pour l'engagement je préférerais à titre
personnel qu'on encourage toutes les
formes d'engagement en particulier le
service civique pour faire enfin
confiance aux jeunes de ce pays
merci monsieur le député pour GDR Soumia
Brouard
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues depuis sa
création les députés communistes et le
groupe GDR ce sont opposés au CNU nous
en dénoncions les écueils qui n'ont fait
SNU pardon excusez-moi nous en
dénoncions les écueils qui n'ont fait
que se renforcer au fil du temps en
particulier au fur et à mesure des
ajustements que le gouvernement effectué
parce que il se rend bien compte que ce
dispositif ne répond pas aux objectifs
fixés tout d'abord le SNU coûte très
cher
140 millions d'euros cette année pour
remplir des missions que d'autres
peuvent remplir éducation nationale
association nous considérons que le SMU
est un dispositif pour tout qui opère
une dangereuse confusion entre l'armée
l'éducation populaire et l'éducation
morale et civique il est d'autant plus
inacceptable que le SNU va désormais
retirer 12 jours d'enseignement aux
élèves alors même que la réforme du
baccalauréat prive déjà des élèves de
plusieurs semaines de cours en raison
des épreuves anticipées une telle mesure
viendrait aggraver la diminution des
volumes horaire d'enseignement dans le
même temps les services publics
sont malmenés les fermetures de classe
continuer les postes de professeurs
diminuent et ne sont pas remplacés dans
certaines académies dans la mienne
l'éducation nationale est dans de
nombreux endroits exemples je porte avec
depuis plusieurs semaines avec plusieurs
collègues de la nupes une proposition de
loi pour le droit aux vacances avec des
mesures très simples concrètes et qui
favorise l'éducation sur ces temps de
vacances et tout cet argent sur la table
sur le SNU la co-tutelle avec le
ministère des armées ça faisabilité plus
que compromise en termes de moyens
financiers de milliards à terme et
d'encadrement du projet alors que nous
aurions souhaité un renforcement
déstructures existantes des outils il en
existe déjà pour favoriser l'engagement
des jeunes et la mixité sociale ces
outils ont besoin d'aide ils ont besoin
d'être aidés et la montée en charge des
30 millions en plus cette année du SNU
nous apparaît irresponsable c'est la
raison pour laquelle madame la ministre
il faut revenir sur cette sur ce
dispositif je vous remercie merci madame
la députée madame Béatrice Descamps pour
le groupe liotte merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre chien tout
d'abord vous remercier de votre présence
pour évoquer ici notre jeunesse nos
futurs citoyens nos jeunes citoyens qui
doivent être placés au coeur de notre
travail d'élus et au cœur de nos
politiques je crois que jusqu'à lors n'a
pas été fait suffisamment et bien sûr
plus précisément aujourd'hui ici
d'évoquer différents sujets concernant
le SMU
il est vrai que la réussite des
objectifs affichés d'une constitue un
véritable défi
qui suscite naturellement des
interrogations
pour les uns des réserves pour les
autres par exemple quand
ton montant de voilà financement alors
que d'autres actions enfin vers notre
jeunesse peuvent également être
envisagées
je voulais faire part de d'une
expérience en circonscription j'ai
organisé il y a quelques temps au sein
de celle-ci une table ronde sur
l'engagement de la jeunesse plus d'une
centaine de personnes dont de nombreux
jeunes n'est pas que des jeunes ont
répondu à cet appel chacune importance à
vision de l'engagement dans un débat
ouvert riche éclairant et même parfois
émouvant je pense notamment aux
témoignage d'Hugo 19 ans qui a expliqué
que le SNU avait provoqué une véritable
évolution de ce qu'il appelait son être
citoyen et de sa façon de penser en
esprit critique les grands défis de
notre société
un représentant du staj de Valenciennes
a expliqué qu'il y avait énormément de
jeunes engagés de différentes manières y
compris dans les quartiers villages mais
ces jeunes de participent pas forcément
au SNU comment peut-on à votre avis
toucher les jeunes plus largement et
donner envie de s'engager jeune issu de
milieux modeste y compris un rapport
sénatorial propose de surseoir au projet
de généralisation du SNU du fait
d'obstacle logistique au titre des
obstacles logistiques il est par
ailleurs très regrettable et
malheureusement contre-indictoire que
des centres d'accueil et là je vais
terminer parce que ça me tient vraiment
à cœur de SNU comme l'école nationale de
technicien de Valenciennes soit fermée
qu'il n'y ait plus lieu de lieu sur le
Valenciennois pour accueillir ces jeunes
quelles réponses pouvez-vous m'apporter
j'avais beaucoup d'autres sujets nous en
parlerons merci madame la députée vous
avez largement débordé et
après je vais être taxé de favoritisme
et je ne voudrais surtout pas
bon c'était parce que non mais je ne
voudrais j'essaye de faire au mieux
madame la ministre vous avez la parole
le président
ce qui est certain c'est que c'est comme
disait
c'est la dernière séance de la session
extraordinaire mais vous avez gardé un
des sujets qui a animé les débats de
l'année donc merci merci pour ça et je
vois que par la qualité effectivement
des questions on peut aller loin vous
savez mesdames messieurs les députés oui
c'est un défi si c'était simple si
c'était simple un je ne serai pas devant
vous ça ne créerait pas autant de débats
si la réponse était unique si le sujet
de l'engagement était aussi évident
alors quel que soit en réalité les
sensibilités politiques la réponse aura
été donnée à aucun moment le service
national universel n'est un projet
exclusif à aucun moment on oppose les
engagements moi je suis particulièrement
fier d'engager d'accompagner
l'engagement des jeunes dans leur
diversité quand ils deviennent scout
quand ils deviennent jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers quand ils rejoignent
une association environnementale ou
quand au contraire ils font le choix
pour le coup de donner leurs après-midi
à la SPA ou de devenir délégué de classe
bien sûr que cette jeunesse là elle elle
prend bon sens la question qui se pose
c'est les autres c'est comment on
reconnaît ceux qui font et qu'on les
regarde et qu'on leur donne de
l'importance mais c'est aussi comment on
fait pour ceux qui ne s'engagent pas ou
qui n'ont pas conscience parfois de la
capacité qu'ils ont à s'engager et
parfois même c'est simplement de
l'autocensure parce que ils n'ont pas le
capital social ou simplement l'offre
territoriale qui leur permet de
s'engager pour faire qu'il se sente
aussi en réalité et bien en capacité de
le faire c'est ça de ma mission c'est
rien d'autre que ça ça ne sera jamais de
créer des hiérarchies dans les
engagements moi j'ai oui mon cœur vibre
quand je vois le 14 au 14 juillet sur
les Champs-Élysées le carré final que ce
soit le carré final des jeunes avec des
jeunes et ses nus des jeunes en service
civique monsieur le député parce qu'il y
a aucun moment j'ai opposé les deux et
la phase 3 du SMU c'est le service
civique comme opportunité quand on voit
des jeunes des lycées militaires mais
aussi des jeunes sapeurs-pompiers
peut-être que ça vous touche pas moi ça
me touche parce que cette jeunesse elle
prend du temps elle prend du temps de
nos villes alors le 14 juillet sur les
Champs-Élysées c'est un moment
particulier mais c'est la reconnaissance
de la nation c'est la reconnaissance de
parcours de jeunes qui font le choix du
volontariat sur leur temps personnel
parfois au détriment peut-être de la
facilité d'être je sais pas dans dans un
moment plus ludique ou plus festif mais
ça les grandit est-ce qu'il est grandir
rend notre pays plus fort et peut-être
que c'est particulier mais moi c'est en
tout cas c'est quelque chose qui me
marque énormément quand on voit dans le
regard de leurs parents la fierté à la
fin d'un engagement d'une remise de
brevets quand on voit les cadets de la
gendarmerie ou la fin du séjour du FC nu
ou même quand on passe dans des un
certain un certain nombre de mouvements
le BAFA ou le baby
on voit une fierté qui est très
particulière et cette flamme là et bien
en réalité c'est la reconnaissance du
parcours qu'il commence à prendre et
donc oui c'est un apprentissage de
citoyenneté et ça ça a du sens et donc
je rentrerai dans l'ensemble des
questions madame la députée
colbuck la question c'est quel projet
comment on va plus loin moi je crois que
pour aller plus loin il faut toucher des
jeunes qui aujourd'hui pour le coup ne
se sentent pas peut-être concernés et
pour ça nous avons besoin de l'éducation
nationale nous avons besoin
d'enseignants qui en parle de
témoignages un tiers des jeunes qui
viennent c'est parce qu'ils ont un des
amis un des copains un voisin qui en a
parlé donc d'abord c'est du témoignage 9
zones sont extrêmement satisfaits
d'avoir fait le SMU donc les meilleurs
ambassadeurs c'est eux-mêmes ensuite on
a une responsabilité forte dans les
encadrants c'est à dire leurs
enseignants les responsables associatifs
mais les parents enfin il y a un moment
le continuum éducatif il prend
pleinement sa part et donc comment on
informe les parents là mesdames
messieurs les députés pour toucher plus
de jeunes moi j'ai besoin de vous de
votre capacité à mobiliser les mers de
mobiliser les structures associatives
que vous connaissez au quotidien on
passe notre temps à dire faut pas que
les politiques publiques soient
construites exclusivement à Paris que ce
soit du descendant plus que jamais je
suis d'accord avec ça et pour ça il faut
de la mobilisation de tous c'est pour ça
que j'avais fait cette invitation toutes
sensibilité confondues pour que
finalement vous voyez de vos propres
yeux pour améliorer parce que oui c'est
un défi et quand il y a des filles il y
a des écueils il faut il faut il faut
être à la hauteur et bien de la
transparence nécessaire la question qui
est un comble c'est comment on répond à
ces écueils et Madame la Députée je
crois pour répondre à votre question
qu'il est aussi nécessaire à la lumière
de la qualité de vos questions d'avoir
un débat parlementaire et de poser les
opportunités les hypothèses à venir
d'une généralisation les formes que ça
pourrait prendre mais je n'ai toutes les
évolutions qui a pu avoir le SMU ont été
faites en concertation avec évidemment
la réception d'annonce un certain nombre
de députés toutes sensibilités
confondues des organisations syndicales
également de l'éducation nationale de
l'éducation populaire mais aussi les une
association de parents et évidemment les
ceux les hommes et les femmes qui aussi
permettent l'accompagnement de ces
jeunes dans les phases d'engagement donc
le monde associatif lui-même et les élus
locaux parce que plus que jamais ce qui
permettent au plus proche de la vie
quotidienne un jeune de s'engager et
bien c'est parfois le maire c'est
parfois l'école ou c'est l'association
qui est en réalité un des piliers du
lien social madame la députée Parmentier
vous avez parlé effectivement d'un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements oui
il y en a bien sûr et ma mission c'est
de les réduire au maximum la question
qui s'est posée c'est dans le fond le
SMU à été victime presque de son succès
pendant longtemps on nous a reprochés et
même parfois très personnellement de ne
pas avoir atteint les objectifs c'est
pas un totem je vous assure je ne fais
pas une course aux chiffres et donc oui
l'année dernière
l'objectif était plus élevé que les
jeunes accueillis mais le plus important
c'était des accueillants de bonnes
conditions de bonne qualité et je n'ai
jamais fait de ce chiffre quelque chose
que je devais juste cocher cette année
nous avons eu la situation inverse nous
avons eu plus de jeunes volontaires en
réalité que de place ouverte pour
répondre à cela l'année n'étant pas
terminée on expertise la possibilité
d'ouvrir un autre séjour d'ici la fin de
l'année pour permettre aux jeunes qui
ont cette volonté de le faire de pouvoir
le faire
exactement donc en priorité ceux qui
n'auront pas dit ceux qui vont avoir 17
ans d'abord dans l'année parce que ceux
qui pourront le faire l'année prochaine
sur les périodes estivales en
particulier vaut mieux les laisser pour
ceux qui ont 15 ans cette année pour ne
pas priver parce que plus que jamais
c'est ce goût de l'engagement qu'il faut
pas qu'il faut pas réduire sur la
question en particulier des transports
et de la et des jeunes qui ne viennent
pas ça arrive ça arrive en fait alors au
dernier moment ou parfois deux trois
jours avant un message disant je ne
viens plus pour les séjours de juin il
fallait s'inscrire en mai au plus tard
et donc face à ça c'est un âge où ce
sont des adolescents donc ça parfois ça
change d'avis le plus important c'est
qu'il puisse nous le dire et donc pour
ne pas priver des jeunes qui sont sur
liste d'attente et bien oui c'est un peu
tard c'est vrai mais c'est une
opportunité de dernière minute disant
mais écoutez on va pas choisir la
facilité de dire bah tu viens pas c'est
pas grave et puis et puis bon bah on
fait le séjour alors on offre la
possibilité de venir à la dernière
minute malheureusement ça implique
effectivement une mobilité
rapide mais du coup c'est là où nous
avons besoin d'un message de
responsabilité un jeune qui s'est
inscrit et qui ne souhaite plus venir il
n'y a pas de drame mais plus vite il le
dit et là c'est vraiment en citoyen qui
doit se comporter plus vite il le dit
plus vite il permet à un autre jeune de
venir et dans des conditions plus
confortables que la dernière à la
dernière minute mais nous ne souhaitons
pas du coup gâcher l'opportunité d'un
jeune si la place est disponible et
évidemment c'est dans les améliorations
qui qui sont en cours vous avez parlé
également madame la députée la question
de la rupture d'égalité
en réalité il n'y a pas de rupture
d'égalité puisque la priorité c'est dans
le monde permettre à tout le monde de
s'engager mais je voulais revenir sur ce
point de la reconnaissance de
l'engagement dans parcours il fait un
certain nombre il pose un certain nombre
de questions c'est légitime ce n'est pas
le exclusivement qui est reconnu dans le
parcours en fait dans parcoursup il y a
une case d'engagement et dans cette case
d'engagement on reconnaît la démocratie
scolaire quand on est éco délégué
délégué de classe au CAVL cévelle quand
on est un bonus quand on est jeune d'un
conseil municipal jeune régional ou
municipal quand on est jeune
sapeurs-pompiers moi ma mission c'est
juste de faire que oui cette jeunesse là
je crois qu'elle mérite qu'on ne le
reconnaisse cette part de de
d'engagement quand on se préoccupe de
l'autre il n'y a pas de raison que ça
compte pour du beurre moi je ne crois
pas moi je crois que c'est très bien et
cette partie là aujourd'hui elle existe
et c'est pour ça que on a ça j'ai
simplement réappuyé que s'engager dans
l'œil nu comme s'engager dans un service
civique ou s'engager dans les cadets de
la gendarmerie ou dans une association
tant que bénévole oui ça compte et dans
le parcoursup c'est normal en tout cas à
mes yeux que ça puisse continuer à
compter comme toutes les formes
d'engagement qu'aujourd'hui nous offrons
plus que jamais on leur permettra
d'avoir plus de place c'est une mission
et en attendant je pense que un jeune en
tout cas qui a envie ma mission c'est
évidemment de faire que la liste
d'attente soit la plus petite possible
mais ça donne de l'espoir pour notre
jeunesse quand je vois ces jeunes avoir
envie et bien ça nous oblige il faut
aller au bout de la démarche sur les
questions madame la députée Périgot sur
les sur les questions les différentes
questions de transmission du goût de la
nation parce que c'est oui ça transmet
en fait ce goût de la nation et c'est
vrai que vous avez rappelé rappelé le
mot le site de Sourdun est magnifique il
est il est particulièrement il est
particulièrement développé mais vous
avez appuyé sur un point je pense qui
est important c'est la question de
l'unité de la formation et du message et
de ne pas laisser s'installer dans des
discours des idéologies pour reprendre
votre mot explicitement pour cela en
fait nous avons une réelle opportunité
qui se développe on fait on est
extrêmement vigilant parce qu'on
l'efforme tout le monde tous les
encadrants sont formés formés à une
pédagogie une pédagogie d'abord active
pour qu'il n'y ait pas ni de laxisme ni
trop à l'inverse de de contraintes qui
ne serait qui serait excessive au cadre
d'encadrement mais ce sont des
professionnels d'encadrement des jeunes
c'est pour le coup ce sont des gens qui
sont formés qui sont diplômés qui
viennent de trois corps différents et en
fait la question qui se pose c'est
comment on fait pour que des gens qui
ont des cultures différentes initiales
éducation populaire associative ou
sportive des gens qui viennent de
l'éducation nationale et des jeunes qui
ont servi sous les sous les drapeaux en
réalité qui viennent vraiment de culture
très différentes intègre une culture
commune dans ce projet là permettant du
coup d'avoir une sorte d'alignement pour
ça des formations bien sûr mais au-delà
de la formation et c'est je crois que ça
rejoint votre inquiétude qui est tout à
fait légitime c'est la question de la
fidélisation de nos encadrants demain et
du coup dès cette année quand j'ai
demain c'est à partir de la rentrée
prochaine nous allons nous projetons
d'avoir des centres permanents ce qui
est une sorte de clin d'oeil à Madame la
Députée décan dans la foulée mais ça
veut dire des centres permanents qui
pour accueillir des classes engagées
tout au long de l'année mais aussi du
coup des encadrants qui sont pérennisés
et de fait nous n'aurons on aura moins
en réalité de recrutement
je veux dire pas au coup par coup mais
ces jours par séjour pour vous donner
une échelle
de vue c'est 15 000 encadrants qui ont
été recrutés depuis le début de 2019
c'est en fait c'est énorme mais nous
sommes particulièrement vigilants et à
chaque fois pour le coup c'est peut-être
la fermeté qui est la mienne mais à
chaque fois que j'ai vu ou que j'ai eu
en réalité une remontée d'une d'un
comportement pédagogique ou de propos
qui ne correspondent pas au projet
philosophique qui est celui du SMU et
bien les mesures les plus les plus
fermes ont été prises ça va évidemment
de la suspension jusqu'à la saisine
parfois d'un article 40 ou de laspection
générale quand c'est nécessaire puisque
je crois que quand les parents acceptent
de nous donner la responsabilité de
leurs enfants ce qu'ils ont en réalité
de plus cher il faut être à la hauteur
de cette confiance
madame
monsieur le député creusier
les propos que vous avez que vous avez
tenu sur oui cette jeunesse qui s'engage
et qui valait construire au plus profond
en fait de notre pays
je crois cette fierté ces liens est
absolument essentiel et ça ne mérite
aucune caricature je crois que devant
votre commission madame la Présidente
mais au-delà à chaque fois qu'un député
quel que soit sa sensibilité ma saisie
apporter des réponses avec évidemment
les défis que ça demande parce que
accueillir en ce moment on est à peu
près à 10 % d'une classe d'âge 80 000
jeunes qui ont fait le SNU depuis sa
création 10% une classe d'âge peut-être
d'ici la fin de l'année ou dans quelques
mois d'ici le peut-être le premier
trimestre qui arrive on sera plus de
100000 jeunes qui ont oui le vin drapeau
chanté une Marseillaise porter ses
uniformes qui sont très loin de
l'uniformité mais qui compte qui crée du
commun en fait ils sont particulièrement
fiers de les porter parce que à un
moment donné à un instant T en réalité à
un instant T il y a aucune différence on
voit pas celui qui a les moyens d'avoir
le polo de dernier cri ou la parka très
étanche hyper cher mais qui est très
agréable l'hiver et celui qui n'a pas
les moyens d'avoir ça à un moment donné
il y a oui un sentiment qui est
essentiel qui est celui de vivre une
aventure qui ne fait de différence que
par le mérite l'effort le goût de la
découverte de l'autre rien d'autre et ça
c'est fort parce que c'est fort ça leur
demande d'aller piocher autre chose dans
nous ils ne viennent pas avec ce qu'ils
ont ils viennent avec ce qu'ils sont et
là pour le coup ça nous demande aussi
j'avoue et madame la Présidente on a
plus que conscience d'aller chercher des
choses un peu difficiles comme
l'interdiction du téléphone portable
durant la journée
oui d'apprendre la Marseillaise ou le
chant des partisans a des jeunes tout le
monde tout le monde le maîtrise pas
alors au début ça rigole c'est vrai un
peu et puis très vite au cours des
séjours et je pense que vous l'avez vu
pour ceux qui ont fait les cérémonies de
clôture ils sont émus ils veulent être
le dernier à l'avoir levé ou l'avoir
chanté et dans le fond ça crée des
amitiés ça crée du dépassement et
j'espère monsieur le député comme vous
l'avez souhaité que oui les préfets les
mers mobiliseront ces jeunes et ses
nuits pour les cérémonies dans nos
territoires s'ils gardent leur uniformes
après le séjour c'est pour voir pour
pouvoir les sortir participer à nos
moments patriotiques et mémorielles et
finalement continu er à faire vivre ce
parcours encore une fois le séjour de
cohésion n'est qu'une étape en réalité
de l'investissement que nous mettons
dans le service national universel
Monsieur Madame la député qu'elle loi
Achille vous avez parlé principalement
de sécurité du temps scolaire
sur la question de la sécurité pour moi
c'est absolument essentiel parce que
j'ai eu déjà cet échange avec un certain
nombre d'organisations syndicales pour
le coup si vous avez été témoin ou qu'on
vous a rapporté des des situations
difficiles vous avez la possibilité
d'activer un article 40 et je vous ai
vraiment c'est une demande à part
entière quel que soit la personne qui
est témoin ou qui a entendu ou qui a eu
vent d'une information doit la saisir ce
sont des jeunes mineurs je ne dis pas
que moi je l'ai activé à chaque fois que
j'ai eu à moindre doute ou la moindre
information franchement vous avez cette
possibilité là je vous invite à
l'utiliser autant que de besoin en tout
cas si si vous en jugez la nécessité
concernant le recrutement madame la
députée chaque homme et femme qui a
encadré ce projet est formé et diplômé
et en réalité et oui et a été contrôlé
madame la députée contrôler parce que
l'honorabilité de ces encadrants nous
mettons des hommes et des femmes
majeures qui encadrent des jeunes
mineurs c'est à dire honorabilité figes
B2 donc question en réalité de violence
pour lutter contre les violences
sexuelle et sexistes et les
condamnations mais aussi du BAFA du BFD
et en réalité des parcours qui sont bien
plus diplômés que ça un tiers de
séquences encadrants viennent du monde
de l'éducation nationale ce sont des CPE
ce sont des proviseurs ce sont des
enseignants en réalité qui viennent sur
leur temps pour participer à ce projet
là ils font ce choix là ce sont des
hommes et des femmes qui encadrent au
quotidien des jeunes oui mais l'autre
terme la député c'est des hommes et des
femmes qui viennent d'éducation
populaire deux tiers le deuxième tiers
vient de l'éducation populaire et c'est
ce qui c'est les médiateurs ces
animateurs c'est le c'est les gens qui
en cas de nos enfants dans le monde
associatif au quotidien que ce soit dans
des colonies de vacances que ce soit en
réalité dans l'extrascolaire le
périscolaire c'est eux madame la députée
qui les encadrent et le dernier tiers
c'est des hommes et des femmes qui sont
des réservistes ou qui ont porté
l'uniforme mais nous le recrutons pas
sans formation commune et particulière
ensuite ils sont en réalité formés dans
un ensemble c'est ce que je disais juste
avant pour avoir
comment de pédagogie mais également de
projets mais au-delà de ça je crois que
plus que jamais il ne faut pas jeter
l'eau propre sur les 15000 hommes et
femmes qui encadrent puisque oui ce sont
des hommes et des femmes qui font ce
choix-là mais c'est des hommes et des
femmes madame la députée qui sont
particulièrement formés et contrôlés sur
le temps scolaire
madame la députée la proposition qui a
été faite c'est loin d'être une
proposition qui est sortie nulle part
c'est une proposition de volontariat qui
a été concertée consultée j'ai commencé
les consultation en janvier et qui a
permis de proposer à des hommes et des
femmes qui le souhaitent d'un engager
leur classe comme on fait un projet
pédagogique comme on fait le choix
d'avoir une classe thématique on a des
classes Arbites des classes défenses on
a des classes culture on a des classes
qui font des voyages scolaires à aucun
moment faire un projet pédagogique
emmener sa classe ou faire l'école hors
les murs n'a été en réalité une perte de
temps je crois que les compétences
développées dans ces temps-là sont une
chance et donc plus que jamais ça
restera le choix des enseignants qui le
souhaiteront ou pas monsieur le madame
la députée par contre pardon Soumia
Bouhara concernant la position du groupe
entre autres gédère il se trouve que
j'ai eu le grand plaisir de débattre
avec
Léon des fontaines qui était à l'époque
le responsable des jeunes communistes et
qui aujourd'hui du coup le porte-parole
indéparent du président Roussel et
Madame la Députée c'était moins
catégorique que ça puisque le projet des
communistes est un brin différent bien
sûr mais il y avait plus de nuances
madame la députée dans dans le débat
c'était à la Fête de l'Humanité il y a
deux ans maintenant pourquoi je vous dis
ça c'est parce que le essai nuit évolue
bien sûr mais dans le fond avec
l'histoire de votre partie il y a un
goût de projet républicain extrêmement
fort de dépassement de l'assignation à
résidence avec une seule émancipation
possible le goût de la République pour
l'emmener un peu plus loin et comment on
fait pour donner à des jeunes qui
viennent de milieux différents une sorte
de confiance en eux plus forte pour que
demain il transforme cette confiance en
engagement qu'un jour ne transforme pas
tout le séjour de cohésion ce n'est
juste que la petite graine qui leur
donne des repères des possibilités une
capacité à se projeter ensuite ce sera
leur parcours individuel qui fera la
différence mais si on intègre générale
engagement long à posteriori sur la
phase 3 et ensuite ce sera les citoyens
qu'il deviendront qui feront en réalité
le visage de notre pays vous avez
également parlé madame la députée du
budget en disant que c'était beaucoup
trop cher d'une certaine manière madame
la députée
140 millions 140 millions pour un projet
qui en réalité vient créer quelque chose
de complémentaire avec les engagements
qui existent pas un euro n'a été pris
sur l'éducation populaire 20 millions
supplémentaires sur l'éducation
populaire cette année 15 millions 15
millions sur l'éducation populaire 20
millions sur le service civique c'est 16
% du budget de la jeunesse
16%. madame la députée le service
civique
580 millions d'euros c'est la phase 3 et
donc à aucun moment il est pertinent
d'opposer engagement citoyen et en
réalité service national c'est en
complémentarité et quand j'entends mais
pourquoi vous ne mettez pas c'est 140
millions dans le projet de l'éducation
nationale madame la députée projet de
l'éducation nationale 59 milliards
d'euros 59 milliards on parle de 140
millions d'euros versus 59 milliards
avec avec une augmentation madame juste
pour donner avec une augmentation en
réalité du budget de 10%. bien sûr que
le ski émancipe c'est l'école c'est ce
qui permet à notre jeunesse d'avoir un
esprit bien fait dans un corps en plus
en bonne santé c'est c'est évidemment le
projet d'un pays c'est le projet d'une
nation que d'élever ses enfants et de
les amener évidemment à ses
enseignements fondamentaux mais
n'opposons pas et c'est pour ça que je
remets un peu de un peu de voilà un peu
de nuance parce que 140 millions sur 59
milliards je crois qu'il y a pas un euro
qui est mal dépensé dans le service
national universel sachant qu'un tiers
et vous allez y être sensible madame la
députée un tiers de la dépense et quand
même un tiers qui est en réalité qui va
aux structures qui accueille les séjours
hébergement confondus et se sont bien
les structures de l'éducation populaire
qui accueillent
madame et pour terminer madame la
députée Descamps vous avez parlé du
témoignage des jeunes et je crois que
votre initiative est extrêmement
importante parce qu'elle permet de
montrer la pluralité des formes
d'engagement sans aucune sans aucune
idée de les hiérarchiser et c'est
essentiel enfin je veux dire s'engager
en réalité dans un EHPAD pour le lien
intergénérationnel s'engager dans le
Souvenir français pour faire vivre des
questions mémorielles s'engager chez JSP
ou encore s'engager dans une association
environnementale il n'y a pas quelque
chose qui vaut plus que l'autre la
question qu'on pose c'est comment on
fait pour qu'il s'engage parce que dès
le moment que tu t'engages et bien tu
prends peut-être plus conscience de la
valeur du commun que nous avons mais
aussi de la place et de la
responsabilité que tu as dans ce commun
et donc on est plus témoin ou juste
juste à regarder ce qui se passe autour
de nous en fait on le bâtit et quand le
bâtit on en prend soin et si on en prend
soin alors le visage de notre société en
réalité se développe madame la députée
sur le point particulier des sites des
sites permanents moi je crois que le SMU
au-delà du projet
que qui permet de développer
l'engagement le goût de l'autre la
responsabilité que chaque citoyen a dans
notre pays il y a une opportunité
d'aménagement du territoire aujourd'hui
127 sites ont permis l'accueil de
presque 17000 jeunes dans les séjours de
juillet on parle d'une généralisation ça
veut dire une montée en nombre en
réalité des capacités d'accueil ça veut
dire aussi des la rentrée scolaire
prochaine des travaux qui nous
permettront d'installer des centres
permanents permettant d'accueillir tout
au long de l'année et donc des
opportunités d'aménagement du territoire
sur des peut-être des lieux qui
permettraient soit de revivre soit des
lieux qui viennent plutôt du projet
voilà du bâti communal qu'on connaît qui
ont qui est un héritage éducation
populaire ou des sites au contraire de
colonie de vacances qui permettent entre
autres de d'avoir un modèle économique
beaucoup plus stable et mesdames
messieurs les députés puisque je regarde
je regarde pourquoi ma droite mais qui
en réalité à la gauche de l'hémicycle
mesdames messieurs les députés
le collectif de l'éducation populaire à
d'ores et déjà proposé plus de 40 sites
qu'ils souhaitent voir comme permanent
n'opposez pas éducation populaire et
projet et projets pédagogiques sur le SM
faisons les faisons évaluer proposons
mais ne caricaturons pas c'est un projet
qui d'abord permet à des jeunes et bien
de faire le choix de servir de se
dépasser et de rendre fier ce qui les
entoure voilà madame la Présidente ah un
dernier point effectivement pardon sur
vacances apprenantes et parce que
c'était le question de l'opposition sur
et pourquoi on met pas plus d'argent en
réalité dans des projets qui permettent
qui permettent le départ vacances
apprenante ça a permis un million de
jeunes de partir dans vacances
apprenante il y a colo apprenante qui a
permis à plus de 250
000 jeunes de partir et ça a été d'abord
une réponse à la crise mais qui a été
pérennité pour la quatrième année
consécutive la question du départ en
vacances est essentielle on y croit
notre pour le coup je regarde la
présente majorité pour le coup le porte
profondément mais le porte avec une
certaine continuité d'abord pour
répondre effectivement aux conséquences
de la covid entre 2000 entre 2009 et
aujourd'hui nous avons divisé par deux
le nombre de jeunes qui ne partent pas
en vacances c'était c'est oui mais
c'était 17% madame la députée oui et
c'est encore beaucoup trop mais ça
aurait toujours beaucoup trop et et on
continuera à avoir cette ce combat
jusqu'au dernier parce que oui c'est
beaucoup trop mais voyons voyons
l'évolution quand divise par deux le
nombre de jeunes qui ne partent pas en
vacances au moins une semaine parce que
la réalité c'est au moins une semaine ça
va dans l'opportunité en tout cas ça va
dans le bon sens et dans les travaux qui
sont menés aujourd'hui il y a un projet
de passe colo qui est expertisé et qui
permettra j'en ai la certitude de
permettre à plus de 80% d'une génération
de partir c'est les travaux que nous
menons entre autres avec plaisir mais
parce que je crois que c'est
complémentaire
mais mais simplement pour vous dire que
oui c'est dans le fond et dans la forme
une continuité et ça vient de
l'enracinement du projet de vacances
apprenante que la main entre autres à
l'époque pour le coup la majorité a
conforté dans ses budget et je profite
pour en remercier parce que c'était une
des réponses à la crise covid voilà
madame la Présidente les réponses merci
madame la ministre nous allons passer
maintenant aux autres orateurs pour une
minute avec Béatrice Piron pour
commencer merci madame la présidente
madame aministre merci pour votre
présence au sein de notre commission ce
matin le mois dernier vous a le mois
dernier vous avez annoncé la mise en
place d'un séjour de cohésion de 12
jours dans le camp du SMN
à compter de mars 2024 il se déroulera
dans le cadre d'un projet pédagogique de
classe cela permettra d'offrir à bien
plus de jeunes l'opportunité de
développer leur culture de l'engagement
et de vivre en séjour dans une optique
de brassage sociaux géographique la
mixité attendue ne pourra résulter que
d'une garantie pour ses élèves d'une
même classe d'être regroupés avec des
jeunes veut tant d'autres horizons
géographiques ainsi que d'autres types
d'établissements scolaires les classes
de CAP seront-elles incluses par exemple
ou uniquement les secondes a-t-on
confirmation qu'il changeront de
département ou de région ou
d'environnement rural urbain par exemple
quelles contraintes allez-vous inclure
dans l'organisation afin d'éviter que
plusieurs classes du même établissement
ou de ville ou d'établissement trop
proche se retrouvent dans le même lieu
au même moment merci merci madame la
députée
mes chers collègues juste si vous
pouviez parler un tout petit peu moins
fort parce que autrement ça fait un bois
et c'est pas très agréable Sophie blanc
je vous remercie madame la présidente
madame la ministre dans une interview au
Figaro du 15 juin dernier vous esquissez
le nouveau format du SNU qui passerait
je vous cite sous une forme de projet
pédagogique de classe et proposer à des
élèves de Seconde
issus des de lycées volontaires et vous
ajoutez il n'y aura pas d'obligation un
peu comme un voyage scolaire alors
passer de un CMU à une sorte je me
permets d'expression de de classe verte
ne me semble pas présenter un signal
fort de la volonté de l'Élysée de tendre
vers un renforcement de la cohésion au
sein de la jeunesse au moment où nous
venons d'assister à des à des journées
des meutres qui ont vu des jeunes gens
scolarisés détruire et brûler des
établissements scolaires de nombreuses
établissements scolaires donc ma
question sera la suivante d'intégration
du SNU au sein d'un des multiples
projets pédagogiques de l'éducation
nationale vous semble-t-il le meilleur
moyen de renforcer la cohésion de la
jeunesse autour de la nation je vous
remercie
merci madame la députée Céline Calvez
si madame le Président Madame ministre
alors que notre société aspire toujours
plus à une meilleure égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il est essentiel
d'examiner comment le SNU y contribue en
effet le s&i permet de renforcer le
sentiment d'appartenance à la nation de
promouvoir les valeurs de citoyenneté de
solidarité tout en favorisant
l'engagement des jeunes il est
primordial que les jeunes femmes et les
jeunes hommes puissent jouer un rôle
actif à ce titre vous nous avez informé
que les filles participaient à hauteur
de 57%, bravo à elle et bravo à vous des
mesures doivent-elles être envisagées
afin d'assurer la participation des
jeunes garçons à cette expérience
nationale par ailleurs le SNU constitue
un outil majeur de formation de la
culturation des jeunes générations afin
d'apporter des réponses concrètes aux
discriminations de genre pourriez-vous
nous confirmer que les activités
réalisées par les jeunes citoyens au
sein du sienu ainsi que leur cadre de
vie lors de ce service prône et assure
le respect de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes je vous remercie
merci madame la députée Paul Vanier
merci madame la présidente madame Lamy
je crois que vous avez bien résumé le
projet que porte votre gouvernement
moins d'école plus de SNU moins d'école
12 jours de moins pour ces séjours de
cohésion que vous envisagez à partir de
l'année prochaine et donc plus de SNU
moins d'école c'est les 1500 postes
d'enseignants qui ont été supprimés par
le dernier budget 2023 et qui vont aussi
avec une augmentation des moyens de 100
millions d'euros pour le SNU ce choix
traduit je crois une conviction
idéologique très marquée presque
caricaturale il voudrait mieux plus
d'encadrement à dimension militaire que
d'encadrement pédagogique pour notre
jeunesse il n'est ainsi pas surprenant
de voir un arc je ne crois pas qu'il
soit si républicain je le décrirai
plutôt comme autoritaire qui va de
l'extrême droite elle l'a exprimé là
vigoureusement jusqu'à la macronie
soutenir votre projet et votre politique
alors qu'à l'inverse de nombreuses
organisations lycéennes des fédérations
parents d'élèves je pense à la FCPE
notamment des organisations syndicales
enseignants dénoncent votre conception
de la place de notre jeunesse et votre
projet de lclu alors là la mise vous
êtes manifestement engagé dans une
entreprise de recomposition idéologique
qui chaque jour vous rapproche un peu
plus du projet de société de l'extrême
droite est-ce que vous allez tenir notre
jeunesse à l'écart de cette entreprise
politique
merci monsieur le député Francis Dubois
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en Corrèze le SNU est un succès
les séjours de cohésion organisés sur le
département ont d'excellents retours et
le dispositif tourne très bien aucune
dérive comme on a pu le voir ailleurs
n'a été constaté les encadrants
mobilisés pour suivre les jeunes sont
très professionnels et performants avec
des profils complémentaires ils font le
preuve d'un engagement sans faille pour
transmettre à la jeune génération les
valeurs de notre République et du bien
vivre ensemble la Corrèze terre de
résistance authentique et chirachienne
reste candidate à l'accueil du séjour
SNU car elle dispose d'un
infrastructures adaptées sportives et
culturelles et de toutes les ressources
humaines nécessaires à la réussite de
l'accompagnement des jeunes au vu de ce
retour d'expérience positive je serai
pour ma part favorable à la
généralisation du SNU pour tous les
jeunes en agit participé sans dispense
il a en effet trop important et même
urgent compte tenu des événements qui
ont secoué récemment notre pays de
consolider chez nos jeunes les valeurs
de respect de solidarité de mémoire
d'inclusion très fort ainsi que le
sentiment de fierté d'appartenance à la
nation nous avons par contre besoin de
plus de visibilité quand une éventuelle
généralisation le président de la
République semblait l'écarter en mars
dernier mais les violences récemment
perpétrées ne changeraient-elles pas la
donne si tel et le cas quel moyen
financier humain doivent être mises en
œuvre pour généraliser un séjour à CNU
sur la base de la cohésion sur les
valeurs de la République et du
savoir-être et savoir vivre quel bonus
supplémentaire afin de récompenser leurs
engagements citoyens je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député melkir
Belhaddad merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre merci pour votre
présence et votre engagement sur ce
sujet je tiens à souligner les retours
positifs concernant le service universel
en particulier chez les jeunes du
département de la Moselle qui ont pu en
bénéficier leur témoignage régulier
mettent en évidence l'impact bénéfique
de ce programme sur leur développement
personnel et l'engagement citoyen c'est
engagement pour se traduire vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure de votre propos
liminaire à travers leur participation
prochain Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques pour faire à la fois
mixité et construire cette nation
sportive le CNU est basé sur le
volontariat qui peut avoir aussi ses
limites et on le voit à travers quelques
enquêtes d'opinion ma question c'est
comment aller chercher ces jeunes très
éloignés de l'école de l'emploi qui sont
parfois en rupture familiale je pense
notamment aux jeunes de nos quartiers
politiques de la ville pour permettre
justement cette plus grande mixité on
sait que c'est un défi vraiment
important merci merci monsieur le député
Bruno Bilde merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre l'actualité récente
avec les émeutes et son lots de violence
nous démontre qu'une partie de notre
jeunesse est complètement désœuvrée et
pour ainsi dire perdu je rappelle que la
moitié des personnes interpellées
étaient des mineurs en effet qu'en
quotidiennement l'autorité de l'État et
attaquer et nos valeurs communes sont
bafouées le SNU pourrait être un
formidable outil de transmission des
valeurs de la République et de l'amour
de la France aujourd'hui son bilan est
contrasté à la frontière entre la
colonie de vacances et le service
militaire coûteux mal encadré le essai
nu Pen a trouvé son public avec un
potentiel de 800000 jeunes concernés
chaque année seul 32 000 participants se
sont lancés en 2022 avec un objectif
annoncé de 50000 comment comptez-vous
transformer le s&u qui tient un plus
aujourd'hui d'un stage accéléré de
citoyenneté en un projet plus ambitieux
plus sérieux plus utile pour que les
jeunes retrouvent ainsi le goût de
l'engagement au service de la France je
vous remercie merci monsieur le député
Eddy boomerti merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre on ne compte plus les
dysfonctionnements dans l'organisation
du service national universel que
politique qualifiée même de bourbiers
logistique les critiques sont nombreuses
et Florence sociologue spécialisés dans
l'engagement et le travail des jeunes
estime même que le SNU est avant tout
une mise au pas de jeunes considérés
comme des sous-citoyens à ce titre
l'aspect militaire du Séni semble lui
fonctionner correctement et le site du
ministère des armées fait même la
promotion d'une préparation militaire
effectuée en février dernier par une
vingtaine de jeunes âgés de 15 à 17 ans
esprit de corps et maniement du fusil
réglementaire de l'armée parcours
d'obstacles et marche suivi d'un bivouac
comme indiqué sur le site c'est aussi ça
le CNU l'aventure madame la ministre
Gabriel Attard votre prédécesseur à ce
poste affirmer que le CNU était la
réforme de société la plus puissante des
dernières années promotion de l'ordre
plutôt que de la loi respect de la
hiérarchie plutôt qu'esprit critique
obéissance plus émancipation est-ce
vraiment là les valeurs que vous
souhaitez inculquer à nos jeunes
merci monsieur le député
Emmanuel
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre en tant que député de
Boulogne-Billancourt je souhaite attirer
votre attention sur une question
importante concernant le service
national universel et plus
spécifiquement les élèves étrangers qui
n'ont pas la nationalité française
inscrit dans la classe volontaire pour
un séjour de cohésion tout d'abord
permettez-moi de saluer les efforts du
gouvernement pour promouvoir la
participation et l'inclusion des jeunes
dans cette initiative ambitieuse le SNU
joue un rôle essentiel dans la formation
citoyenne et le renforcement des valeurs
communes et les crucial que tous les
jeunes indépendamment de leur
nationalité est la possibilité d'y
participer pleinement
cependant je m'inquiète de savoir
comment le SNU aborde spécifiquement la
situation des élèves étrangers inscrit
dans la classe volontaire ma question
est la suivante quelle mesure concrète
sont mises en place pour garantir que
les élèves étrangers inscrits au SMU
bénéficient d'une expérience aussi
enrichissante et inclusive que leur père
français tout en respectant leur
identité culturelle et leur diversité
linguistique merci infiniment merci
Monsieur député
merci madame le Président Madame le
Ministre je ne vais pas développer ni
poser mes questions puisque vous l'avez
largement abordé dans votre intervention
cependant je voudrais vous remercier
pour votre dynamisme 27 inspirer
réellement aujourd'hui dans la
présentation du SMU peut-être ajouter
que c'est un moyen également se
dispositif d'un moyen quand même
qui qui est intéressant pour nos jeunes
et qui pourraient être largement
valorisés dans un CV
merci monsieur le député pour cette
question brève et concise qui n'était
pas une question mais c'était
angélique
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues bonjour et
merci pour votre venue j'ai beaucoup
aimé les mots d'un sapeur-pompier
encadrant le séjour à Douai qui
expliquait au journal cassettage les
jeunes sont des éponges et que c'est le
bon moment pour leur inculquer les
valeurs et l'esprit de cohésion
c'est d'autant plus vrai après les
crises de violence de la part des
mineurs que la France a traversé
dernièrement le séjour à l'équilibre
entre loisirs et discipline oblige les
jeunes à se retrouver sur un pied
d'égalité et semble faire naître des
amitiés des réflexions et des
comportements jusqu'à leur insoupçonner
chez certains et c'est une très bonne
chose
cependant la physionomie du public
accueilli manque de représentativité en
2022 un tiers avait un parent issu du
corps en uniforme alors qu'il représente
seulement 2% de la population il ne
faudrait-il pas accélérer
l'expérimentation pour la générer la
généralisation afin que l'ensemble des
jeunes se sentent concernés dès
maintenant enfin combien de lycées se
sont portés volontaires pour celles-ci
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
Fabrice le vigoureux
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre il y a souvent dans les
témoignages et dans la voie des plus
anciens de notre pays une émotion toute
particulière lorsqu'il relate leur
période de service militaire devenu
service national en 1997 puis Service
Volontaire une émotion parfois nourrie
par des amis si tu es anciennes
persistantes et scellé durant cette
expérience de vie de jeunesse si
structurante avec en filigrane la mise
en exergue des vertus
qu'on ne retrouvait pas toujours
ailleurs d'un brassage et qui
transcendait les origines sociales des
uns et des autres ma question est donc
relative au profil des volontaires du
SNU comment mieux favoriser la mixité
sociale au sein du s&u au regard des
chiffres de l'INJEP d'octobre 2022 je
crois qui montre une sous-représentation
des publics issus des quartiers
prioritaires et des enfants d'ouvriers
par exemple je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député Lisette Pollet
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre le service national universel
va-t-il devenir obligatoire cette
question est sur toutes les lèvres des
lycéens le président avait en effet dès
sa campagne présidentielle de 2017
assurez-vous renforcer le lien armé
nation grâce à la mise en place d'un
service national de durée courte
obligatoire et universel à cause du défi
logistique cela ne pourra pas se faire
du jour au lendemain cette
généralisation va-t-elle se concrétiser
une partie de notre jeunesse est perdue
on voit que les repères nationaux
s'effritent et que beaucoup de ne se
reconnaissent pas dans nos valeurs
républicaines le s&u pourrait être une
machine formidable pour créer des
citoyens français c'est un beau projet
sur le papier mais dans la réalité c'est
plutôt un flop alors que l'objectif
avait été fixé à 50
000 jeunes de 15 à 17 ans en 2022 ce
32416 ont participé l'an passé comment
allez vous faire pour rendre ce projet
plus ATT
s'il est obligatoire à quel moment sera
mis en place les jeunes feront-ils leur
stage de deux semaines pendant le mois
de juin après après la fin des cours où
voulez-vous inscrire dans le temps
scolaire sur la forme de module de
quelques heures par mois je vous
remercie madame la député Véronique
criotton merci madame la Présidente moi
aussi j'apporte à la fois un témoignage
et peut-être une question un témoignage
en Haute-Savoie le FC nu ça marche bien
je trouve que cette initiative répond en
tout cas des besoins qui sont égales
partout sur le territoire pour autant on
trouve encore beaucoup d'enfants de
cadre d'enfants de gendarmes d'enfants
qui volontairement sont déjà éveillés
finalement de ce qu'ils vont trouver
dans ce temps-là et donc pour moi la
question de la mixité est une une
question très importante je suis de 69
et donc du coup mon époque les garçons
faisaient encore le service national et
pour moi le lieu où les gens du Midi
rencontrer ceux du Nord les cadres
rencontrés les ouvriers la question
d'illettrisme était traitée donc c'était
vraiment un passage qui qui avait une
vocation de citoyenneté qui permettent à
nos jeunes de faire nation donc sans
revenir évidemment sur ce qui a été fait
et ravi que notre armée soit aujourd'hui
professionnelle je partage l'idée de la
généralisation j'aimerais avoir votre
avis sur notre
rapport du Sénat et notamment sur les
enjeux financiers merci madame la
députée Roger judo
je vais trois questions qui sont
politiques et non polémiques les
vacances approchent on va voir se
détendre un petit peu la première
alternative à l'obligation on était
posée par les êtres paulets à l'instant
le gouvernement a-t-il l'intention de
rendre le Séni obligatoire et si oui
avec quel budget quel calendrier
deuxième question si le demeure
facultatif moi pendant quelques années
comment être plus incitatif en direction
des publics de jeunes qui en aurait le
plus besoin je pense notamment aux
jeunes qui habitent les 300 quartiers
prioritaires de la ville
pouvez-vous entreprendre quelque chose
de plus direct pour eux enfin une
question relative à la l'articulation
entre le SNU et le lycée enfin ne
pensez-vous pas qu'il faudrait réfléchir
une convention entre le Ministère
d'éducation nationale et votre ministère
pour que le et ce nuque trouve sa place
dans le mois de juin toute façon est à
moi perdu n'est-ce pas le ministre vient
de découvrir mais c'est comme ça depuis
30 ans et ça pourrait être utile pour
tout le monde je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député et je pense que
tous les enfants et tous les jeunes sont
égaux devant la volonté ou pas de faire
le SNU et qui a pas forcément plus de
quartiers à Visé voilà Pierre Cordier
non c'est pas la police de la pensée
c'est on dit que c'est si cet universel
c'est universel Pierre Cordier
bien merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre merci pour vos mots on sent
bien que vous êtes effectivement une
passionnée dans le cas de vos missions
ministérielles simplement vous
transmettre aussi finalement un
témoignage plus personnel puisque moi
j'ai eu l'honneur effectivement de faire
mon service militaire comme beaucoup de
personnes dans cette pièce et je dois
bien dire que j'en tire quelque chose de
très positif je suis de la 96 10 je
faisais mes études c'était pas simple
non plus il a fallu arrêter les
reprendre après etc je suis allé
jusqu'au bout du bout mais ça n'a pas ça
n'a pas été simple mais en tous les cas
vous dire que les personnes que j'avais
côtoyées qui venaient principalement
d'outre-mer d'ailleurs m'avait aussi
appris beaucoup de choses enfin il y a
une vraie transmission de vrais échanges
et je veux aussi vous dire parce que
souvent c'est pointé du doigt
en disant ouais super le service
militaire c'est arrêté mais en tous les
cas il y a eu un certain nombre de
choses qui m'ont été transmises et j'ai
appris beaucoup
évoquer aussi par rapport à ce qui a été
évoqué mon étonnement par rapport aux
chiffres que vous avez donné des 5,7%
seulement d'enfants issus des quartiers
présents dans le cadre du SNU c'est
quand même un chiffre qui est très bas
et qui interroge et moi je pose aussi la
question ça a été évoqué par certains
collègues est-ce qu'on ne pourrait pas
par rapport à des jeunes qui ont été
interpellés à l'occasion des événements
qui sont déroulés il y a quelques
semaines dans notre pays leur dire vous
irez passer quelques temps ou essayer ça
vous fera pas de mal et moi je crois
aussi énormément à un moment ou un autre
à la transmission d'un certain nombre de
valeurs et de respect des valeurs de la
République ça me paraît important j'ai
rencontré aussi vous étiez parti avec 30
secondes qui n'étaient pas décompté
monsieur le député donc vous avez déjà
largement entamé le temps
donc voilà
Monsieur le monsieur le député je je
juste
monsieur le député juste je vous disais
pourquoi je tapais mais je
j'ai bien compris que vous n'aviez pas
vu donc je vous laisse poser votre
question et puis voilà mais pas
continuer à tout contextualiser sur la
question vous pouvez vous poser votre
question
non mais il faut il faut juste que vous
repreniez le micro autrement vous
n'entend pas et c'est pas enregistré
donc si vous voulez bien poser votre
question
non bon ben écoutez si vous avez décidé
de faire
c'était juste
c'est vraiment
oui je pense que là je danse dans cette
commission dont vous êtes un visiteur
régulier vous savez que ça se passe
comme ça qu'effectivement je tape pour
prévenir que ça va être fini mais j'ai
bien compris c'est pour ça que je vous
ai indiqué pourquoi ça s'était passé
comme ça maintenant si vous n'avez pas
envie de poser votre question vous ne la
posez pas madame la ministre vous avez
la parole pour les réponses merci merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente
juste peut-être commencer par la
question qui a été posée par notre
collègue Béatrice Béatrice Piron sur le
brassage territorial et la mixité il
faut essentiels et quand on parle de
mixité souvent on a le réflexe de penser
à la mixité sociale mais en réalité ce
qui est important c'est de penser au
mixité au pluriel mais que c'était
territoriale et social social bien sûr
et ça on regarde en réalité le les
métiers des parents les origines
sociales mais aussi comment on crée
cette
cette unité par les territoires les plus
ruraux les territoires les plus urbains
le périurbain c'est des réalités de vie
qui ne sont qui sont quand même assez
différentes et pour ça même dans le
projet parce que c'était une inquiétude
en tout cas qui était soulignée et
légitime dans le projet des classes
engagées madame la députée même si la
classe va au même lieu elle ne reste pas
ensemble et donc du coup en fait la
mixité elle est construite par la
composition des maisonnés et donc les
jeunes ne se retrouvent ne restent pas
dans un dans un groupe classe
exclusivement au contraire ils sont
mélangés en fonction évidemment des
territorialités qui sont qui sont les
leurs donc la mixité va va dans ce sens
madame la députée Sophie blanc vous avez
repris une de mes expressions pour le
coup dans le Figaro effectivement où
j'ai parlé de voyage scolar je vais
expliciter ma pensée le cénu
effectivement ce n'est pas un voyage
scolaire mais pourquoi j'utilise cette
expression c'est plutôt dans les
modalités et en fait les modalités du
voyage scolaire vont correspondre en
réalité aux modalités de contrainte du
du projet service national universel
classe engagée pour être plus explicite
encore concrètement ça veut dire quand
une dans une classe il y a un voyage
scolaire et que un parent ne souhaite
pas que son sa fille ou sa fille partent
en voyage scolaire il peut évidemment où
elle peut évidemment le refuser ce sera
en réalité cette modalité là qui
correspond mais j'aurais pu être plus
explicite je vous l'accorde le projet en
tant que tel ne change pas le Seigneur
reste le SMU mais cette particularité
c'est simplement pour illustrer que le
volontariat de la classe ne vient pas ne
va pas contre
l'autorisation nécessaire du parent qui
garde l'autorité bien sûr sur sur les
enfants voilà pour l'explicitation en
tout cas sur le voyage scolaire et la
question l'année de seconde madame la
député calvaise merci de souligner la
forte mobilisation des jeunes filles et
pour être aller dans votre sens c'est
une mobilisation et une représentation
plus forte qui se confirme d'année en
année donc c'est pas un séjour en
particulier qui marque quelque chose je
crois que ça signifie quelque chose ça
signifie une volonté plus forte de
s'engager d'être dans des engagements
qui sont peut-être beaucoup plus
universel parce que peut-être plus
récent c'est une génération qui cale
goût de cette égalité réelle en fait et
là pour le coup ça va ça va dans le sens
pour garantir en réalité les besoins
fondamentaux de la compréhension de
notre société pendant le service
national universel évidemment il y a les
questions de consentement qui sont
évoqués dès le début parce que
rappelons-le ce sont déjà dans 15 et 17
ans qui viennent au milieu très
différents qui ne te connaissent pas et
donc il faut du commun et ce commun
passe par les règles communes évidemment
les questions d'emploi du temps bien sûr
mais surtout les questions évidemment de
violence sexuelle excessive de
consentement de harcèlement et donc à
partir de là on repose les questions
d'égalité immédiatement dès le début du
séjour et c'est souvent d'ailleurs deux
trois jours après que la parole commence
à se libérer et qu'il y a pas mal de
témoignages et parfois de fait la
saisine ben des procédures nécessaires à
postérieure monsieur le député Paul
Vanier vous avez vous avez eu des propos
extrêmement durs en fait contre les
jeunes qui s'engagent ce député les
jeunes sont libres de s'engager là où
ils le souhaitent oui contre moi aussi
mais bon le coup monsieur le député pour
contre moi j'ai l'habitude mais pour le
coup moi ma mission c'est de ne pas être
la police de la morale jugeant les
engagements des jeunes ces jeunes là le
souhaitent le souhaitent ils viennent
ils participent et ils font le choix en
plus derrière pour plus de 70% d'entre
eux de faire leur mission d'intérêt
général dans la même année je vois pas
pourquoi ces jeunes seraient moins bien
accompagné que d'autres au contraire
monsieur le député chaque jeune a le
droit et la liberté encore heureusement
dans notre pays bah finalement de
choisir ce qui le ce qui le touche le
plus et j'en profite dans la foulée pour
également répondre à la question de
votre de votre de votre collègue qui
était sur la promotion du s&u sur les
sites des armées le monsieur le député
bien sûr que c'est la promotion elle est
faite sur le site de l'éducation
nationale sur aussi des armées et quand
vous parlez de cet article en
particulier où il y a un maniement aux
armes le maniement aux armes n'a
aucunement lieu dans le séjour 1 dans la
phase ces jours de cohésion par contre
les jeunes sur leur mission d'intérêt
général ils peuvent choisir de s'engager
dans une préparation militaire comme ils
peuvent choisir de rejoindre la SPA ou
les jeunes sapeurs-pompiers ils sont
libres de leur choix donc un jeune qui
choisit dans la mission d'intérêt
général de rejoindre une préparation
militaire et bien j'en suis aussi fier
qu'un jeune qui fait le choix de
rejoindre la Croix-Rouge et donc nos
armées se mobilisent aussi pour
permettre des engagements et ce qui est
assez intéressant c'est de voir que et
bien cette jeunesse pour le coup même
quand elle ne souhaite pas faire de
carrière militaire derrière a envie pour
une partie d'entre elles de découvrir et
bien les hommes et les femmes qui nous
protègent au quotidien et protègent en
réalité un socle de valeur bien au-delà
donc monsieur le député cette
publication est tout à fait normale
puisque c'est la liberté du jeune
liberté individuel de chaque jeune de
choisir la forme de l'engagement qu'il
souhaite et je pense que ça éclaire du
coup votre question puisque ce n'est pas
la phase une qui est pour le coup la
phase commune et qui est totalement
civile ou évidemment il n'y a pas de
maniement aux armes puisque ça n'a pas
ça n'a pas cette vocation là concernant
monsieur le député
du bois
je vais vous recherchez du voyage c'est
pour ça merci pour pour vos mots je
pense que vous avez plus que raison
quand vous parlez du savoir-vivre que ça
que ça dont ça fait la promotion je vous
assure monsieur le député il y a des
jeunes qui qui viennent et qui ont la
chance d'avoir des parents extrêmement
mobilisés à leur côté qui ont déjà
intégré un certain nombre de règles de
vie en collectivité d'autres ce n'est
pas le cas c'est une réalité toi ce
n'est pas le cas certains jeunes qui ont
l'habitude de de collectif parce que
scoutisme ou colo mais
quand communauté de destin et de partage
de temps d'autres c'est pas le cas et
donc la question de qui que pose le
séjour également de cohésion c'est
finalement comment on fait pour pour
créer du commun des repères qui leur
permettront à eux en réalité de trouver
aussi d'avoir les codes dans une société
qui leur demande d'avoir des codes
partagés mais ma mission c'est aussi de
faire que ces engagements citoyens ils
sont au pluriel parce que je disais en
fait on leur présente on leur propose
ils rencontrent plus des hommes et des
femmes passionnés souvent en plus des
élus des bénévoles des enjeux et cette
passion de l'engagement devient en tout
cas à mes yeux c'est un essentiel ça
devient pour eux des visages des rôles
modèles mais des héros du quotidien les
routes de notre quotidien de notre vie
commune et dans le fond ça leur donne la
capacité peut-être parfois se projeter
parfois à dépasser des conceptions
d'interdiction dans lesquelles il s'auto
censuré ou se priver en tout cas de
capacité à se projeter ça leur permet
aussi et ça rejoint les propos de du
député Cordier ça permet aussi de
rencontrer des jeunes très différentes
soit monsieur le député Cordier moi je
suis particulièrement attaché au fait
que des jeunes de l'Hexagone partent en
métropole et que déjà de des métropoles
viennent dans nos dans nos séjours en
dans l'Hexagone parce que oui c'est ces
territoires font France et on a besoin
en fait qu'ils vivent aussi des temps de
comité alors les voyages sont un peu
plus longs mais en général les jeunes
métropolitains qui partent en outre-mer
sont très heureux d'avoir été dans les
dans les dans les grands chanceux qui
font qui font le départ mais c'est c'est
comme ça qu'on crée c'est comme ça qu'on
crée quelque chose qui nous transcende
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'on se dépasse
c'est un projet c'est un idéal et en
fait cet idéal il faut qu'il puisse se
rendre compte qu'ils ont tous leur part
dedans et ça va dans le sens de vos
propos une généralisation oui sans
dispense c'est la question qui se posera
mais en réalité ça répond à un certain
nombre de questions pas de dispense ça
veut dire obligatoire obligatoire ça
veut dire débat parlementaires ça veut
dire évolution législative et la seule
et unique possibilité en réalité c'est
la responsabilité et la force cas
évidemment la représentation nationale
de faire évoluer ce projet ce qui est
certain c'est que moi ce que je suis en
train de construire aujourd'hui c'est
l'acceptabilité la plus forte le défi
logistique les centres permanents la
capacité à accueillir humainement et
ensuite arrivera à se débat
parlementaire et ce sera mesdames
messieurs les députés votre volonté ou
votre voilà votre swing fera que
l'évolution restera sur de l'incitation
ou au contraire sur une obligation mais
c'est d'abord c'est d'abord
effectivement une évolution législative
concernant quand même ce qu'on peut
faire pour aller un peu plus loin si on
souhaitait le rendre plus incitatif
encore plusieurs pistes sont à l'étude
dans le programme présidentiel se poser
la question du permis de conduire à un
moment donné sur un cycle long la
question arrivera à un moment ou un
moment ou un autre évident dans le débat
c'était un des sujets dans le programme
moi je pense aussi à un certain nombre
de possibilités qui sont en discussion
mais qui sont aujourd'hui pas
suffisamment murs pour être totalement
arbitré ça va de la reconnaissance dans
le parcours scolaire à la question du
BAFA au PSC1 il une diversité où on
parle aujourd'hui aujourd'hui beaucoup
de la formation des gestes qui sauvent
de santé mentale le PS2 pour ceux qui
ont déjà le PSA mais en fait faut
permettre quelque chose qui est la
reconnaissance de celui qui donne et
c'est l'équilibre entre ces droits et
ses devoirs on donne on reçoit et
inversement et je pense que ça va plutôt
dans le bon signe monsieur le député
Belhaddad vous avez parlé de la question
de la capacité que le sport permet ça je
connais votre engagement sur les
questions du sport mais au-delà de ça
vous avez parlé de la mixité comment on
va chercher des jeunes qui sont plus
éloignés encore ce qui
peut-être ça ne traverserait à qui ça ne
traverserait même pas l'esprit de
s'engager première
prescripteur si vous me permettez
l'expression c'est d'abord évidemment
les camarades de classe mais c'est aussi
et surtout les enseignants les le monde
associatif et plus particulièrement sur
vous avez parlé des quartiers populaires
ou des enfants plus éloignés je pense
aux enfants qui sont aujourd'hui sous la
protection de l'enfance il y a des
jeunes qui sont plus vulnérables en
réalité pour eux nous faisons des
partenariats avec des associations en
réalité territorialement enracinés ou
qui porte des projets je pense à face
parce que c'est voilà c'est les années
que j'ai en tête qui vont en réalité
aller plus plus en profondeur dans la
sensibilisation la présentation du
projet mais j'en profite parce que et
encore beaucoup de parlementaires et
députés qui sont présents il y a des
maires qui font le choix de mettre une
note d'information par exemple dans leur
bulletin municipaux ça compte ça compte
beaucoup enfin bon je sais que je moi je
suis local donc je lis évidemment
bulletin mais en fait beaucoup de gens
lisent le bulletin municipal et je vous
invite voilà peut-être en tout cas si
vous pensez que c'est pertinent d'aller
chercher cette mixité également
d'utiliser les moyens qui sont les
moyens citoyens de notre vie quotidienne
monsieur le député build vous avez parlé
d'amour de la France il se trouve que
c'est les propos du de Léon Gautier du
héros Léon Gauthier qui a été le dernier
du commandant qu'il fallait à qui on a
rendu hommage c'était ses propos face à
un déjeune du SMIC qui était dans le val
Calvados tout le monde à plus avec l'âge
qu'ils ont mais pourquoi vous êtes
partis rejoindre général de Gaulle avec
beaucoup de naïvetés pourquoi il aura
répondu on m'a appris à aimer la France
je crois qu'effectivement ça s'apprend
ça s'apprend à l'école ça s'apprend dans
les engagements ça s'apprend par aussi
le regard que vous vous portez sur eux
quand vous partez témoigner ils se
rendent compte que du coup ils sont
importants aussi pour des gens qui sont
importants et c'est vous vous portez des
mandats et les ambitions puisque vous
avez posé un certain nombre de questions
aujourd'hui les ambitions qui me sont
donnés les objectifs qui me sont donnés
c'est poser les bases d'une
généralisation plus forte c'est à dire
une administration centrale il y a une
délégation générale avec la tête une
préfète parce que c'est d'abord sur nos
territoires une Dazaine parce que c'est
avec le monde de l'éducation nationale
un général cinq étoiles qui est en 2s
aujourd'hui parce que oui c'est avec le
soutien de nos armées mais également des
structures du monde associatif qui ont
une autre culture sportive de médiation
parce que les jeunes ne viennent de
milieux différents et donc de culture
différente c'est important de bien
construire le commun en s'appuyant sur
toutes les forces vives de notre pays
mais comme j'ai répondu au député du
bois sur la question en réalité de
l'obligation l'obligation c'est une des
hypothèses qui pourra un moment avoir
lieu si le débat parlementaire a lieu
c'est d'abord c'est d'abord une
évolution en attendant moi je construis
les opportunités permettant d'accueillir
plus de 10% d'une génération mais quand
on y pense c'est déjà presque 80 000
jeunes qui l'ont fait en fait et c'est
le service civique c'est plus de 600 000
jeunes en disant
cette jeunesse s'engager elle existe
maintenant on peut créer du commun plus
fort ça j'en ai la certitude monsieur le
député
boomerti j'ai pu répondre mais à la
question dès le début mais du coup il
nous a quitté sur la question de la
préparation militaire monsieur le député
pèlerin sur la question des classes qui
est partie évidemment toute la classe
pourra partir il faut il n'y a pas de il
n'y a pas de de
jeunes qui ne pourraient pas partir en
ce genre de cohésion quel que soit pour
le coup la nationalité même si les
séjours volontaires restent sur réservés
aux strictement aux jeunes aujourd'hui
français de 15 à 17 ans mais il n'y a
aucune man enfin fait pas de tri dans
une classe ce sont des jeunes qui sont
scolarisés sur dans notre dans notre
territoire monsieur le député fait vous
avez mille fois raison sur la question
du CV parce qu'en fait un recruteur il
voit quoi il voit comment on voit un
jeune qui a laissé nu qui avait fait qui
a des responsabilités associatives il
voit quoi il voit un jeune qui a fait le
choix donner de son temps qui a
développé des compétences je pense à des
chefs scout mais c'est à dire qu'il a
managé d'autres jeunes ça veut dire que
il a le goût le goût de l'autre ça veut
dire que quand il passe le BAFA qu'il
est formé parce qu'aujourd'hui on peut
passer BAFA des saisons qu'il est formé
à l'encadrement à l'écoute mais ça veut
dire qu'il a une part il va chercher
quelque chose de l'autonomie et donc
dans un CV oui ça compte ça compte
beaucoup et on voit énormément
effectivement d'entreprises qui
deviennent des amis du service civique
pour le couple parce que c'est la phase
3 c'est la phase où on devient plutôt
majeure et je pense que cette évolution
est très large on découvre aussi des
métiers pas mal de métiers alors des
métiers plutôt du la fonction publique
des corps des corps uniformes du monde
associatif l'économie sociale et
solidaire mais on a aussi découvert des
exploitations agricoles parce que oui
l'évolution de l'unité passe par la
compréhension de territoire et la
diversité des milieux donc ça va
totalement dans le sens de vos propos
madame angélique Franck
où je vous fais la réponse en quelques
mots mais pour le coup ce sont des
éponges oui 1000 fois c'est pour ça qu'à
15 à 17 ans c'est le bon âge alors même
que accompagner des mineurs à plus de
responsabilité qu'un compagnie des
majeurs mais c'est un choix d'abord pour
les jeunes que nous le faisons et vous
avez parlé de la de la question de la
mobilisation et de la mixité puisque un
tiers des parents était des hommes et
des femmes en uniforme alors c'est une
lecture très large c'est pas que tu
demandes des parents mais c'est
quelqu'un dans sa famille on était ça
peut être un grand-père un oncle et
franchement je suis fière que ils y
soient qu'ils soient là maintenant en
fait la proportion baisse aujourd'hui
parce que le projet c'est de plus en
plus connu et comme il est plus connu il
y a plus de famille qui viennent c'était
aussi essentiellement un projet je pense
de un sujet de notoriété de
compréhension du projet qui au début
était une expérimentation de un peu
moins de 1000 jeunes donc ça va plutôt
dans le sens de la mixité plus large
aujourd'hui et territoriale qui était
assez juste dès le début mais plutôt
dans les métiers et pour aller au bout
de l'exercice madame monsieur le député
le vigoureux sur le suivi oui ninjep
suit chaque année les séjours de
cohésion et en réalité les rapports de
l'INJEP sont particulièrement précieux
sur les évolutions sociales de mixité
mais aussi les retours d'expérience que
nous amène un certain nombre de jeunes
qui nous font évoluer sur soit les
modalités par exemple
de présentation des je pense de certains
ateliers je pense qu'ils sont
environnemental par exemple en fait on
s'est rendu compte qu'ils étaient déjà
très au courant et donc ils voulaient
plutôt être dans dans du fer que dans du
descendant enfin c'est des évolutions et
donc le le suivi de l'INJEP et précieux
dans son évolution mais aussi dans le
regard sociologique qu'il permet donc
esthétique madame la députée Lisette
Pollet pareil c'était obligation loi
elle est voilà c'était le dans la foulée
mais il n'y a pas de module séquencé je
pose le truc l'évolution elle est quand
même elle passe par le nombre et la
capacité à accueillir il y a la
reconquête du mois de juin à avoir bien
sûr c'est une c'est essentiel les
séjours se passeront tout au long de
l'année mais il faut aller jusqu'au bout
de l'année c'est pour ça que les
programmes ils sont pensés jusqu'à la
fin juin et donc quand on prend deux
semaines dans le cadre d'un projet
pédagogique ce n'est pas deux semaines
en moins c'est deux semaines
d'apprentissage différent mais pas ses
conseils madame la député Riotton sur la
question de la mixité c'est plus que
jamais évidemment
cette nécessité aussi d'évaluer en fait
pour être sûr que cette mixité elle est
elle évoluait les rêves ça va dans le
bon sens tout à l'heure je parlais
évidemment des 5,7% 9% des jeunes sont
aujourd'hui en territoire plus populaire
et plus difficile mais en fait on peut
aller beaucoup plus loin moi j'en ai la
certitude et il faut un peu peut-être
plus aussi embarquer les parents engager
les parents par un certain nombre de
réunions qui sont également dans
l'établissement scolaire pour informer
sensibiliser et créer aussi la confiance
je pense que ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
anodin monsieur le député tu dois vous
avais parlé effectivement des questions
plus polémiques mais en fait il n'y a
aucune polémique puisqu'il y a qu'un
totem la question d'obligation j'ai pu y
répondre sur la question du budget elle
évolue en fonction en fait du nombre
vous savez plus on a de d'uniformes plus
on a de centres enfin plus le coût
unitaire baisse aujourd'hui c'est 2200
euros de budget individuel pour chaque
jeune mais c'est une économie d'échelle
comme comme beaucoup sinon les
incitations j'ai pu en parler permis
BAFA reconnaissance et puis regarde la
nation je pense que le regard qui est
posé aussi par les élus et les
structures associatives sont
essaissances essentiels et le et
Monsieur le Député Cordier pour la fin
le service national universel évidemment
dans toute la mixité je salue le
souvenir qui a été le vôtre avec vos
collègues du service militaire
aujourd'hui nos militaires sont des
militaires professionnels mais reste la
volonté d'avoir une armée de réserve
forte et donc de l'opérationnel on peut
tous s'engager chacun à la possibilité
de le faire à nous de présenter les
engagements en tout cas qui sont
essentiels en permettant à chacun de ne
pas être assigné ni à son ni à son
capital social mais en réalité à
simplement ce qu'il sait et pour ça
c'est une des opportunités une démarche
elle est loin d'être exclusive mais elle
n'est pas inutile en tout cas je c'est
la certitude que j'ai réussi à
construire ces trois dernières années
effectivement sur la question de la le
cellule n'étant pas une c'est pas une
punition par contre ce qui est du coup
pas ceux qui ont été interpellés parce
que franchement ça permettrait le risque
c'est ça serait de changer l'ambiance
même dans les séjours de cohésion et
c'est pas c'est pas l'idée par contre ce
qui est certain et pour le coup je quand
ils font un service national ou quand
ils ont un engagement citoyen non ils
vont pas s'attaquer à une mairie un
drapeau ou à une école parce qu'ils ont
le goût de la chose publique par contre
ceux qui ont été interpellés évidemment
la réponse pénale doit être ferme la
réponse un peu sérieux éducative
également et je pense que des stages de
citoyenneté on a un certain nombre de
réponses qui existent pour les parents
pour les plus grandes mineurs mais
également pour les enfants et ça sera la
responsabilité pour le coup de la
rentrée de voir qu'elle va être la
réponse mais il faut pas que ça reste un
peu ni ça c'est la certitude que je peux
partager avec vous merci monsieur le
député
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
toutes ces réponses et pour votre
engagement et la passion que vous y
mettez donc mais nous nous retrouverons
cet automne pour l'examen des crédits de
la mission jeunesse sport et vie
associative mais mes chers collègues ne
partez pas tout de suite parce que avant
de nous séparer nous devons procéder à
la désignation des corps-à-porteurs de
deux missions d'information pour la
mission sur le financement public de
l'enseignement privé sous contrat j'ai
reçu les candidatures de Monsieur Paul
Vanier pour le groupe LFI à l'origine de
la demande et de Monsieur Christopher
Weissberg nouveau membre renaissance de
notre commission pour la mission sur le
sport au travail je vous propose de
dessiner monsieur Carlo livre du groupe
Renaissance qui en a demandé la création
et Madame Claudia roux du groupe
socialiste apparenté en effet l'idée de
constituer une mission d'information
commune à notre commission et à celle
des affaires sociales a été abandonné
faute de députés de l'opposition de
cette commission volontaire et
disponible pour y prendre part
s'il n'y a pas d'objection il en est
ainsi décidé ainsi s'achève des travaux
de notre Commission au titre de la
session extraordinaire et nous nous
retrouvons le 20 septembre